Chaos Radio. Der Computerblumen bei Fritz. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, außer dieses Mal. Kein April Scherz am ersten des Monats, denn die Cebit stand ins Haus. Dazu ein, zwei Sätze gleich, ansonsten wird es heute aber um was ganz anderes gehen. Herzlich Willkommen sagt der Chaos Computer Club und Johnny.
George Orwell würde sich wundern. Der große Lauschangriff ist schon seit Jahren Realität und erhält nun auch durch den passenden Gesetze die entsprechende Rückendeckung. Auf allen Fronten sind die Regierenden auf dem Weg, die Orwellsche Vision zu übertreffen. Neben den Klassikern der Überwacherung sowie das Abhören der Privat- und Arbeitsräume sowie von öffentlichen Plätzen haben die Dienste nun vor allem das Internet in Visier. Was die NSA, der Amerikaner, schon seit langem macht, soll nun auch in Europa hufähig werden. Das vollständige Durchleuchten der gesamten Kommunikation. Das private Verschlüsselung, da ein Dorn im Auge ist, ist klar. Chaosradio berichtet von Systemen und Methoden, die schon heute zum Einsatz kommen und in Kürze die Arsenalen der Überwachenden bereichern werden. Tipps zur Lauschverhinderung und zum Zurücklauschen inklusive.
Die. Chaosradio bei Fritz, es geht um den Überwachungsstart. Ihr habt es gerade gehört und es geht natürlich wie immer auch um die Musik, die hier läuft. Das, was wir hören, kommt diesmal vom Analog Club DJ Team und das ist alles Abhörmusik. Heute im Moment noch zu zweit, an sich aber zu dritt. Tim ist hier, Andy ist hier und Frank ist auf dem Weg. Wer hat jetzt vielleicht im Autoradio?
Irgendwie noch in der S-Bahn, ja.
Am S-Bahn-Radio dann? Vielleicht hat er so ein kleines zum Umschneiden.
Läuft da jetzt auch schon Fritz irgendwie in der S-Bahn?
Überall.
Naja, nicht überall. Es gibt hier so ganz grausame Tankstellen, zum Beispiel in der nächsten Umgebung.
Laufahmer Ohrenstelle.
Da läuft also nicht nur super schlechte Musik, sondern da kann man auch nicht mal was zu Essen kaufen. Also es ist nichts, wo man das Gefühl hat, dass man den nächsten Tag überlebt.
Aber 28 Biersorten.
Aber 28 Biersorten gehört, ist allerdings auch eine Tankstelle, die den Spruch hat, heute schon getankt oder so was. Oder ich hab wieder voll getankt oder so was.
Heute schon nachgetankt.
Ja, irgendwie so in der Richtung.
Auf jeden Fall ist das alles ganz eklig und widerlich.
So, bevor wir eigentlich in die Thematik anscheinend, wir werden später erst mit euch telefonieren, ihr da draußen an den Empfängern. Denn, achso, Fritz chat ist natürlich auch auf www.fritz.de slash speakers. Da sind auch schon einige Leute drin. Ihr könnt nachher auch anrufen, allerdings erst später. Denn zum Thema Überwachungsstaat, werden wir euch heute erst mal einiges an Informationen bieten, technische Informationen, politische Informationen, alles was dazugehört und nachher natürlich auch mit euch diskutieren.
Und euch ein paar Fragen stellen. Genau, Fragen, Fragen, Fragen.
Aber erst gibt es vielleicht ein, zwei Sätze. Hacker der Woche brauchen wir glaube ich nicht kürten, ist klar.
Ja die sind sozusagen schon gekürt, das stimmt.
Von allen möglichen Medien, muss man dazu noch was sagen von eurer Seite?
Naja ich weiß ja nicht ob jedem so klar geworden ist, was da eigentlich wirklich passiert ist. Da müssen wir jetzt auch nicht unbedingt groß aufkochen. Also in Prinzip haben die halt irgendwas.
Die haben heute schon mit 30 Journalisten am Telefon erzählt, ich will nicht mehr.
Warum musst du denn, ich meine Andi ist ja Sprechersprecher des Chaos Computer Clubs unterwegs und dann rufen tatsächlich die ganzen Zeitungen an und sagen, ja was ist denn damit hier online passiert bei euch?
Wir sind da irgendwie so eine Übersetzungsinstanz geworden für fachunkundige Journalisten, die halt irgendwas lesen, das nicht verstehen und die man brauchen, der ihnen das Journalisten-kompatibel oder teilweise eben auch Krawatten-kompatibel dann ausdrückt, je nach Zielpublikum und erklärt, wie die Welt funktioniert.
Dafür kann man dich im neuen Wired bewundern.
Ach, ich hab das noch nicht gesehen, das muss nun sein.
Warum habt ihr verdammt nochmal hier kein Internet?
Wir haben doch Internet.
Es gibt hier aber keine Ethernet-Dose, hier gibt es eine Rolls-Bars-Taste.
Weil da sitzen die Gäste, die sollen nicht im Netz surfen, die sollen reden. Das Radio.
Gäste, zwei Klassensysteme ist das hier.
Ach, Drei-Klassen-System.
Widerlich.
Ich bin ja in der Mitte.
Ja, der ist im Wired mit einem dieser so Comic-artigen Fotos, die sie auch im Konrad hatten. Da stehen aber ein paar nette Sachen bei.
Nackt im Internet.
Wobei man sich über Wired ja in den letzten Ausgaben doch erheblich aufregen konnte. Und ich war wirklich drauf und dran, einen der ersten, ich hab schon mal diese Briefe geschrieben, einen der ersten Leserbriefe zu schreiben, was für ein imperialistischer Scheiß da abgelassen wird. Haben aber dann die Leser alle gemacht, erstaunlicherweise. Also Thema Gentechnik und so kamen da doch einige Artikel, die äußerst bedenklich waren, finde ich. Und tatsächlich sind in der neuen Ausgabe eine ganze Menge Leserbriefe zum Thema, die die Zeitschrift zu richtig schön wissen. Und halt sagen, sucht euch mal ein bisschen besser aus, wie ihr das schreibt. Fand ich sehr interessant. Ja, so viele kleine Hubschritte nach Amerika.
Kann ich jetzt gerade leider nicht nachklicken.
Musst du ja auch nicht. Würde ich aber gerne.
Schon wieder diese Informationsgefühle.
Außerdem ist doch die ganze Print-Ausgabe überhaupt nicht im Netz von Wired. Hot Wired ist doch völlig anders thematisch.
Das mag sein, aber weißt du halt gar nicht, ob da schon einer gescannt hat.
Keine Ahnung. Ich könnte es hier machen, aber ich habe da auch keine Zeit. Muss ja moderieren. So, kam hier übrigens gerade eine Anfrage im Chat, ob die Chaos-Jungs doch am Freitag auch im Privatclub waren. Wahnsinn, ein paar, ihr seid gesichtet worden.
Allerdings war das auch nicht so schwer euch zu sichten, weil ihr euch alle gleich oben auf das Podest gestellt habt, die Arme verschränkt habt, neinander hingestellt habt, alle dasselbe T-Shirt anhatten.
Insofern konnte man euch relativ leicht erkennen.
Nein, das waren nur unsere Avatarin, die wir vorgeschickt haben. Wir haben uns hinten irgendwie bequem bei Kaperinja gelümmelt und haben uns nicht weiter zu erkennen gegeben.
Für zu auch.
Wie war es denn auf der CeBit?
Anstrengend.
Es war nur lustig oder anstrengend. Beides.
Wir hatten sozusagen Country und Western. Na ja, wir hatten halt einen Stand. Darauf wirst du sicherlich anspielen. Der war wieder mal gut besucht, das uns sehr freut. Da war immer eine Menge los. Und dann hatten wir ja dann diesen besagten Dienstag. Wir haben ja so diese Schwäche, dass wir uns immer gerne Dienstags treffen. Und das natürlich dann auch auf der CeBIT. Und so die ganzen letzten lieben langen Jahre hat sich so bei uns so ein Ritual eingebürgert, irgendwie bei den großen Monopolisten der Telekom aufzutauchen. Und irgendwie hat uns das dieses Jahr echt angestumpt und haben wir das mal sein lassen. Aber treffen mussten wir uns dann natürlich trotzdem. Und haben das Ganze dann gleich in eine Preisverleihung umgewandelt.
Und wer hat da was für einen Preis bekommen?
Ja, die Torte des Jahres haben wir dann sozusagen verdienen. Haben wir auch eine richtig schöne tolle Torte gekauft. Und die konnten natürlich an niemand anders gehen, an die Firma Microsoft. Wer jetzt seinen Webbrowser zur Hand hat, kann sich dann auch das ganze Ritual schön angucken. Auf www.ccc.de haben wir das alles schön mal dokumentiert, was da abging. Es war eigentlich ganz lustig, so mit 200, 300 Leuten. Keine Ahnung, wie viele da tatsächlich waren. Aber es war halt alles voll. Der ganze Microsoft-Stand war halt da. Microsoft war sozusagen gezwungen, uns da offiziell zu empfangen und irgendwie die Kameras zu ertragen, als wir ihnen halt diese Chaos-Knotentorte in die Hand gedrückt haben.
Und immerhin waren sie so weit irgendwie wach ihres Geistes, dass sie sich dann auch revanchiert haben und uns also ein Monopoly geschenkt haben unter dem Motto, so funktioniert das nun mal mit dem Kapitalismus. Da kann man jetzt halt an Meinung sein, ich hab das irgendwie von Anfang an versucht.
Sagen wir mal so, man hätte sich was Witzigeres ausdenken können.
Ja, man hätte sich was Witzigeres ausdenken können.
Von Microsoft aus natürlich ein Monopoly schenken.
Ich fand das eigentlich von ihrer Position aus her eigentlich ganz gut. Weil ich meine, dass sie das Monopol haben, das haben wir ja behauptet und das haben sie dann damit auch gar nicht dementiert. Sondern wir haben sozusagen intelligent darauf angespielt und gesagt, naja, hier irgendwie dann übt schon mal mit Stil Geld. Kann man gelten lassen.
Aber auch auf einem Monopoly merkt man das, wenn man das Geld nicht unter die Armen verteilt und solidarisch unter den Spielern aufteilt und nicht jeder ein Gewinner ist, dann macht das irgendwie auch keinen Spaß. Ich hab versucht zu zweit zu spielen mit meiner Freundin und wir sind kurzer Zeit darüber eingekommen, dass wir uns das Geld teilen, alle Gewinner sind und irgendwie andere Dinge.
Ja, so kann man natürlich nicht nur im Monopoly, oder?
Was ist das?
Sag mal aber, beim Thema Geld. Du hast gerade erzählt, die Zeitschriften rennen euch die Türen ein, wollen von euch Übersetzungen haben, was sie schreiben sollen. Ihr macht diese Aktionen auf der CeBIT und auch nicht nur da. Es gibt den Chaos Kongress. Man liest viel über euch, ihr werdet immer wieder gerne zitiert als Chaos Computer Club. Das ist eine generelle Frage, die vielleicht einige am Radio interessiert. Trotzdem ist es ja ein Verein. Der trägt sich hauptsächlich durch Spenden. So richtige Einnahmen gibt es nicht. Das habe ich schon öfter per E-Mail bekommen, die Frage von irgendwelchen Kids. Gut, die Datenschleuder verkauft ihr, das Chaos Computer Club Magazin, was wir auch am Ende der Sendung noch mal sagen, dass man das natürlich auch alles bestellen und kaufen und kriegen kann. Aber gerade so Kids schreiben immer wieder eine E-Mail, wie ihr denn davon lebt. Ihr lebt nicht, ihr seid nicht Chaos Computer Club und macht euch damit einen Lens. Ihr habt alle noch Berufe, die zwar auch in größtenteils computerbezogen sind. Manche haben keine.
Naja, ich habe höchstens eine Berufung. Es ist halt so, der Club selbst finanziert niemanden direkt. Aber es sind natürlich schon Anfragen, die auch vermittelt werden, die auch irgendwie Leute machen. Ich lebe nur von Vortragsgeschichten und erkläre halt Krawatten, wie das alles funktioniert. Oder erzähle ihnen halt, was sie nicht zu tun haben und was sie zu tun haben. Und sicherlich schlängelt sich der eine oder andere da anders durch.
Ja, aber was so an Vergütungen bezahlt wird für irgendwelche Medienauftritte oder so, das geht natürlich dann im Wesentlichen in die Clubkasse, die nicht besonders reich gefüllt ist.
Hier gibt es ja auch nicht viel Geld.
Ja, schon gar nicht regelmäßig.
Also das ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen...
Aber lass uns nicht mal Geld drehen. Das ist doch als wenn man... Also das ist eben nicht auf dieses Monopoly-Spiel einlassen, denke ich. Das ist die falsche Strategie.
Genau, wir brauchen kein Geld.
Wir sind immer Chef, ich bin heute umsonst hier.
Nee, nee doch nicht.
Ach Geld, das sind nur Zahlen auf Papier, Johnny. Löse dich mal von diesen irrlichen profanen Dingen.
Es gibt aber auch diese...
Chaosradio zum Überwachungsstaat. Die Diskussion um den Überwachungsstaat hat ihren Höhepunkt nach der Nazi-Zeit eher in den 80er Jahren. Aus Anlass der Volkszählung gab es nicht nur eine große Diskussion über Unsinn und Sinn von staatlichen Datenmengen, sondern im Orwelljahr 84 kam da noch so einiges anderes zusammen. Dann aber kamen die 90er Jahre und andere Gefahren zusammen mit der Liberalisierung sozusagen. Da schien das zunächst einmal so, als wenn ihr die ungezügelte Betätigung von Wirtschaftskonzernen eine Gefahr für Freiheit und freie Betätigung ist. Datenspuren von elektronischen Zahlungsmitteln und Konsumforschung bietet sicherlich genug Material für so manchen Albtraum, soll aber nicht das Thema der heutigen Sendung sein. Spätestens seit dem Versuch des deutschen Innenministers Kanter, unter Verschlüssungstechnik zu reglementieren, ist auch den Computerfreaks klar, dass da was faul ist im Staat in Deutschland. Unter reglementieren ist dabei der Verbot, all jener Verschlüssungstechnik zu verstehen, die es auch dem Staat unmöglich macht, die verschlüsselten Texte oder Gespräche mitzuhören oder zu lesen. Ein Vorschlag, der ungefähr so toll klingt wie ein Gesetz, das es jedem Bürger vorschreiben würde, einen Zweitstüssel der eigenen Wohnung bei der örtlichen Polizeidienststelle zu hinterlegen. Chaosradio will sich dieses Mal daher nicht nur mit den technischen Bedrohungen des freien und selbstbestimmten Lebens auseinandersetzen, sondern auch ein wenig die politischen Verhältnisse beleuchten, die auf diesem Planeten den Bau und Einsatz solcher Techniken ermöglichen. Aus Anlass der Volkszählung beschäftigte sich sogar das Bundesverfassungsgericht mit dem Thema selbstdrohenden Überwachungsstaates. Das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung wurde damals aus dem Recht auf freie politische Betätigung und dem Recht auf Teilnahme an Veranstaltungen abgeleitet. Wer nicht mehr weiß, was andere über ihn wissen, so das Bundesverfassungsgericht, der wird versuchen, all das zu vermeiden, was andere ihm übel nehmen könnten. Diese permanente Angst etwa um negative Vorbelastung bei der Bewerbung um einen Arbeitsplatz verträgt sich aber nicht mit einer demokratischen Gesellschaft, die auf dem Recht auf Freie auch politische Betätigung des Einzelnen aufbaut. Und noch mal zur Musik, die ist vom Analog Club DJ Team, Abhörmusik von Pod und Psylla.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünder, dann 100, 1.
Das Echo zum Schluss. Jetzt ist es 22.30 Uhr. Die Bemühungen um ein Bündnis für mehr Lehrstellen sind zunächst gescheitert. Bei einem Treffen von Bildungsminister Rutgers mit Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften gab es keine Ergebnisse. Herangabende Gewerkschaften werden im Herbst mindestens 70.000 zusätzliche Lehrstellen gebraucht. Fahnder. Nach dem Wegfall der Grenzkontrollen zwischen Deutschland, Österreich und Italien gibt es bei einigen deutschen Politikern Bedenken. Bundesinnenminister Kanter und sein bayerischer Kollege Beck Stein forderten die Einführung eines sogenannten Sicherheitsnetzes. Dabei kann die Polizei Reisende im Hinterland der Grenze ohne konkreten Verdacht überprüfen. Störfall. Wegen eines Lex im Kühlsystem ist ein Reaktor des Atomkraftwerks Ignalina in Litauen abgeschaltet worden. Es sei keine Radioaktivität ausgetreten, so die Betreiber. Die Reaktoren in dem AKW in Litauen sind vom selben Typ wie die im ukrainischen Tschernepül. Vor dem Halbfinalspiel der Champions League zwischen Real Madrid und Borussia Dortmund kam es am Abend im Bernabéu-Stadion von Madrid zu einem Eklat. Während der Vorstellung der Mannschaften rissen Fans des gastgebenden Teams Verbindungsstangen ein und brachten so eines der Tore zum Einsturz. Dadurch begann das Spiel erst 75 Minuten später. In dieser Nacht im Fritz-Hadeland zeitweise Regen, über dem Oderland und der Nier-Lausitz gibt es Hagelschläge. Temperaturen zwischen 6 und 10 Grad morgen am Tag da meist regnerisch bei 8 bis 15 Grad. Wir haben keine aktuellen Meldungen, weiterhin eine gute Fahrt.
Das war Matthias Karkow mit dem Fritz-Kurz-Info. Warum vergesse ich immer diese Dinger einzustellen?
Live in Berlin. Donnerstag, 14.
Block 1 Videoüberwachung. Auf der Cebit letzte Woche demonstrierte eine bulgarische Firma ein Bilderkennungssystem anhand von Videoaufnahmen von beliebigen Autobahnaufnahmen. Auf dem Videobildschirm waren schnell vorbeifahrende Autos in größerer Menge zu sehen. Auf dem Computerschirm zusätzlich noch ein Fenster mit Analyste, schnell dahin ratternder Autokennzeichen, die dabei ermittelt wurden.
Wir begrüßen jetzt erst mal Frank. Hallo Frank, du hast es geschafft.
Ja, trotz der Widrigkeiten des Nahverkehrs und den herfolgenden Leistungen der S-Bahn, die es nicht für nötig ist, Pendelverkehr anzukündigen, habe ich es dann noch her geschafft.
Du bist sozusagen hergependelt.
Ich bin sozusagen hergependelt in einer Rekordzeit von zwei Stunden kürdig Berlin.
Das wird bis überwacht worden dabei.
Also ich habe 14 Kameras gezählt auf meinem WG.
Und wo waren die so?
Na die hingen so an den Bahnhöfen.
Von wie vielen Kameras haben dich gezählt?
Wahrscheinlich noch ein, zwei mehr.
Das ist nämlich so eine Sache mit diesen Kameras. Wer von euch schon mal ein bisschen sich umgeschaut hat, Bahnhöfe ist ein gutes Beispiel, da hängen schon eine ganze Menge. Ist ja eigentlich auch nichts Neues hier im Berliner Raum. Die Kameras hatten wir ja auch vor zehn Jahren schon eine ganze Menge.
Also die neu ist die Qualität von dem, was aus diesen Bildern gemacht wird.
Und die Intensität der Überwachung ist auch schon ziemlich anders, weil die Kameras natürlich auch billiger sind, dann kleben die halt überall hin, wo sie gerade noch so hinpassen. Aufheben.
Naja, ich meine, ich denke, es gibt zwei Aspekte. Der eine Aspekt, über den wir später reden, ist das mit der Sicherheitssimulation. Das heißt, dass durch Kameras natürlich auch ein Gefühl von Sicherheit erzeugt wird, genauso wie Mitfahrende irgendwie, wie heißen diese Leute da?
Arbeitslose in Uniform?
Genau, Mitfahrende, Arbeitslose in Uniform, die sozusagen mit einer Uniform den Eindruck erwecken, irgendwie Ordnung herzustellen.
Die sogenannte Sicherheitssimulation.
Die mitunter auch Fahrkarten kontrollieren, die interessanterweise immer dann, wenn man sich neben einem Junkie setzt, übrigens nicht Fahrkarten kontrollieren, oder zumindest nicht den Teil des Waggons, das ist jetzt also mir schon mehrmals passiert. Weil sie da Angst haben, aber über diesen Teil der Sicherheitssimulation wollen wir eigentlich später reden, jetzt wollen wir eigentlich erstmal mit der Technik reden. Und mit Videobildern ist es ja dann eine Sache. Die Erkennung von Gesichtern ist sozusagen eine alte Wissenschaft. Da gab es verschiedene Modelle, also den Abstand der Iris, auch zur biometrischen Sicherheitsauthentifizierung neuerdings benutzt. Also wenn man beispielsweise an einem zukünftigen Geldautomaten im Jahre 2000 schieß mich tot dann also Geld abheben will, dann sind diese Automaten mittlerweile auch in der Lage, ein eigentliches Zwillinge voneinander zu unterscheiden.
Also mit schieß mich tot kleiner Zehen, das ist durchaus eine Technologie, die es bereits gibt. Wir hatten ja nun gerade die Cebit und da gab es doch diese tolle Halle 23.
Genau, die Sicherheitshalle. Die hast du dir doch glaube ich ein bisschen eingeschaut. Das interessante war, dass biometrische Technologien können als beharrscht gelten. Also es ist halt nichts mehr, wo man noch eine Weile rumforschen muss, sondern das ist halt sozusagen erkannt. Es gab ungefähr 10 Firmen, die diverse Pattern-Matching-Technologien im Videobereich vorzuzeigen hatten. Angefangen von Autos über Gesichter. Eine sehr interessante Sache war, da gab es eine kleine Firma, die hatte Optical Tagging im Angebot. Und zwar funktioniert das ungefähr so, wenn ein Detektiv im Warenhaus das Gefühl hat, irgendjemand könnte ein Warenhaus-Tiep sein, dann steigt er sich von hinten an den Rand und sprüht ihm hinten so eine unsichtbare Flüssigkeit auf die Jacke, die halt oft im Infrarotbereich auf den Kameras super grell ist. Und dann können die halt einfach mit den Kameras Bewegungsprofile aufzeichnen, wo er sich da in diesem Warenhaus bewegt, ohne dass sie noch irgendwelche Sachen machen müssen, außer diesen weißen Fleck zu verfolgen.
Jetzt nur durch Beobachtung oder dann schon mit digitaler Auswertung?
Mit digitaler Auswertung, so. Also da ist dann, war da, war da, war da, war da. Und dann müssen sie halt, aha, damit müssen wir suchen. Und irgendwie hat er sich lange vor dem hochwertigen Perfumes aufgehalten. Geht halt beim nächsten Mal Waschen wieder raus, ist nicht zu sehen, so halt solche Geschichten. Und die sind natürlich für die Ermittlungsbehörden auch irgendwie von äußerstem Interesse solche Sachen. Anderen Trend, den ich gesehen habe, war, dass ISDN-Aufschaltung von So-Sicherheitskameras offenbar jetzt Standardtechnologie ist. Also es hat halt mehrere Vorteile für die, für die...
Das ist übrigens nicht nur Standardtechnologie, sondern es ist mittlerweile von den Versicherungen vorgeschrieben, dass diese Überwachungskameras über ISDN das online abliefern können.
Ja, Moment, da geht es um Alarmanlagen. Da geht es also um die Fernbeaufsichtigung von Gebäuden beispielsweise. Und da ist es in der Tat so eine Versicherungsgeschichte.
Also die Sachen, die ich da gesehen habe, da war es so, dass Systeme angeboten wurden, also schon eine Komplettlösung, wo man halt 20 Screens vor sich auf dem Bildschirm hat, wo dann halt die Überwachungssysteme sind. Automatisch werden die Bereiche, wo was passiert, also wo eine Bewegung ist, vergrößert auf dem Schirm. Es werden solche Sachen gemacht, dass werden Bewegungsmelder ansprechen bei Objekten, die Videokameras eingeschaltet und per ISDN aufgelegt werden. Und es geht sogar so weit, dass Kopieschaltungen vorhanden sind, um, wenn halt irgendwie eine besondere Situation ist, dann kann man den Polizeiknopf drücken und dann wird per ISDN das Bild auch noch zur Polizeiwache sozusagen weiter durchgestellt, dass die das dann auch gleich mitverwenden können. So solche Geschichten. Also diese Videovermittlung über ISDN ist sozusagen noch mal die nächste Technologie-Ebene.
Anderer Stichwort, was ich aufgreifen wollte, war diese Sache mit dem Pattern-Matching. Sollte man sicherlich nochmal erläutern, das ist nämlich ein echt heißes Ding. Also Pattern-Matching, das ist das, was man heutzutage so im... Also die Ergebnisse davon sieht man heutzutage, wenn man sich sowas wie Titanic anschaut oder so. Also Filme, wo viele Computer schöne Bilder rechnen. Und da denkt man, ach, wie schön. Hollywood bringt uns so viel Spaß. Und die tolle Software, die da programmiert wird, die ist ja auch nur für unser Entertainment.
Und da geht es...
Willst du mir das Wort entreißen gerade?
Nein, ich dachte eigentlich, ich drehe es dir im Munde um.
Also, mal kurz bei dem Ding zu bleiben, Pattern Mitching, ist einfach die Technologie, mit der Bilder nachbearbeitet werden können. Da gibt es diese Post-Production-Systeme bei Hollywood-Systemen, da wird also das, was bei den Filmaufnahmen gefilmt wird, digitalisiert. Und dann sind da irgendwelche Wackler und Ruckler drin. Dann werfen die halt ihre Software auf den digitalisierten Kram an und erkennen halt diese Ruckler und können das digital rausrechnen, um dieses Bild sozusagen, das Wackeln zu erkennen und korrigieren zu können, brauchen sie automatische Bilderkennungssysteme. Und diese Bilderkennungssysteme, die arbeiten halt mit so Algorithmen, in denen sich Pattern-Matching erkennen, also irgendwelche bestimmten Bildmuster und können danach das Bild ausrichten. Und das ist mittlerweile so weit, dass sie also problemlos oder mehr oder minder problemlos fahrende Autos, Pflanzen, dünne Pflanzen, die sich irgendwie bewegen, erkennen können und das gesamte Bild daran ausrichten können. Ein Abfallprodukt davon ist das so was wie Gesichtserkennung. Heutzutage technologisch überhaupt gar kein Problem mehr ist. Also das ist sozusagen etwas, was nebenbei abfällt. Und diese Firmen, die halt solche Systeme herstellen, die verkaufen also in zunehmendem Maße jetzt auch in diesen Sicherheitsbereich rein. Da wird diese Technologie, die kaufen sich irgendwie Programmierer aus Russland, die vorher an Wilderkennungssystemen gearbeitet haben, um irgendwelche fliegenden Raketen anzuhängen.
Wieso ist denn die Reihenfolge inzwischen?
Also wird sowas entwickelt von z.B. Firmen, die für Hollywood Software entwickeln und kommt dann in den Security Bereich oder wird es im Security Bereich entwickelt und kommt dann aus dem Land an?
Also in den USA ist es traditionell so, dass die Forschung sowieso im militärischen Bereich getan wird. Da wird viele, viele Millionen rein investiert. Deswegen haben die auch so einen riesigen Militärapparat und unglaublich viele Firmen, die dafür produzieren. Und hier in Deutschland, wo das ja alles eher unprofessionell arbeitet und wo sie dann ein paar Jahre später mal feststellen, die Amerikaner haben ja das schon wieder, das brauchen wir jetzt auch. Und stellen halt teilweise fest, dass es sich auch schon im Mainstreambereich teilweise befindet.
Ja gut, aber auf der anderen Seite, es gibt halt eine Sicherheitsindustrie. Und diese Sicherheitsindustrie, die hat halt ihre eigenen Messen. Auf der CeBIT ist das nur am Rande. Und diese Messen, die werden halt auch für staatliche Stellen sozial veranstaltet, wo dann eben die Herren vom BKA oder vom LKA rumwandern. Und dann eben dem, ach, hier haben wir doch eine kleine süße, bulgarische Firma für Bilderkennung von Gesichtern. Auch wenn die irgendwie autonom sich schwarz vermummen, so sieht man doch zumindest noch ihre Augen. Und diese Augen reichen eben aus, um das den Reichen zu identifizieren und mit der Datenbank abzugleichen. Und eben vollautomatisch zu erstellen, wer mit wem, in welcher Reihe, in welchem Blog und so weiter und so fort was getan hat. Das heißt, im Grunde genommen kann man das... Kleines Experiment. Kann man das gar nicht mehr sagen, wer da jetzt wem beißt. Und ich glaube, wir prübeln uns jetzt mal ganz kurz hier intern, drehen die Musik nochmal hoch.
Gut, ihr könnt euch hauen.
Also es besteht keine Gefahr für die Hörer.
Moment liegt an die Vorre. Zuerst haben sie da sehr zögerlich irgendwie angefangen damit, weil die Technik halt teuer war und die Installation schwierig und so. Man musste halt lange Kabel durch die Gegend ziehen und so. Und dann gab es halt diesen Zwischenfall am Alexanderplatz, als ich weiß nicht ganz genau wann es war, irgendwann in den 70er Jahren, dass da so eine richtig heftigen Hooliganrandale kamen, wo irgendwie richtig viele Bereitschaftspolizisten von den Hools verprügelt wurden und irgendwie alles drunter und drüber gegen uns, glaube ich, sogar ein, zwei Tote gab. Und sozusagen die Situation im Wesentlichen außer Kontrolle war und da haben sich dann gesagt, nee, das kommt nicht nochmal vor. Und haben halt die gesamte Innenstadt von Berlin, wie auch die in Dresden und Leipzig, komplett mit Kameras geflastert. Das war teilweise verdeckt, teilweise offen. So umgegeben vom Alex konnte man es ganz gut sehen. Es waren halt so richtig dicke, große Kästen, so diese Wetterschutzgehäuse. Und nach der Wende haben wir uns das mal angeguckt, was die da eigentlich mitgemacht haben und wie gut diese Kameras sind, weil die gab es ja dann im Stasi-Ausverkauf. Und da waren schon ziemlich erhebliche Zoom-Abjektive dran, die also mit denen man also tatsächlich von oben, von der Hausecke runter auf dem Alexanderplatz Gesichter so bildschirmfüllend reinbekommen, dass man die Leute auch verfolgen konnte. Die haben da halt die Identifizierung von notorischen Unruhstiftern noch ziemlich per Hand mit so Fotokarteien gemacht. Also die haben halt so große Wände voll gehabt mit Fotos. Das ist noch so ein Fotoalbum, in dem sie halt nachgeguckt haben, ob das jetzt ein bekannter Störer oder gar bekannter Westjournalist ist. Das haben dann halt entsprechend ihre Teams dirigiert. Was halt immer noch Standard ist, sowohl bei den Sicherheitsbehörden als auch damals im Osten, war, dass halt die offene und die verdeckte Überwachung parallel funktioniert. Das heißt, ein paar Kameras sieht man, die hängen da schön groß. Und ein paar Kameras hängen da genau, wo man denkt, dass keine Kameras hängen und man denkt, da seine Sachen begehen zu können. Also gerade so in Supermärkten zum Beispiel ist es halt so, dass immer Kameras irgendwo rumhängen, so ganz deutlich sichtbar. Und dann gibt es halt noch diese ganz kleinen, die gerade nur so ein Stecknadelkopf, großes Loch brauchen. Die sind dann halt genau hinter den Regalen montiert, wo dann halt irgendwie die teuren Sachen drin sind oder so. Naja, dass diese Videoüberwachung so rauskam sozusagen nach der Wende, gab es so einen kleineren Skandal, wo halt irgendwie dann noch die Zentrale der Nakaibe-Straße irgendwie im Fernsehen gezeigt wurde, wo dann halt der Operator da saß und versuchte irgendwie zu verbergen, dass der Zoom noch irgendwie deutlich weiter reingeht, als irgendwie jetzt irgendwie erst vorzuführen gedachte. Wir haben dann den größten Teil der Technik schon rausgeräumt gehabt, um die Leute nicht allzu sehr zu verschrecken und meinten, nein, das dient alles nur der Sicherheit und der Verkehrsüberwachung. Und ihr wollt ja nur den Überblick behalten. Na ja, so halt alles ganz sicher.
Danke.
Ihr hört das Chaosradio im Blue Moon bei Fritz. Das dreht sich um den Überwachungsstart. Wir hören einiges über Videoüberwachung zur Zeit, denn wir räumen erstmal mit der Technik auf. Es gibt erstmal technische Informationen zum Thema Überwachung. Um so eine, also wir haben von diesem Pattern Matching, heißt es, gesprochen, dass man also Gesichter erkennen kann, selbst wenn man nur ein Teil des Gesichters auf der Kamera hat oder Tracking. Auf dem Monitor, Video Tracking, Pattern Matching. Dazu braucht man aber auch eine Datenbank schon mal von Gesichtern, um die dann elektronisch vergleichen zu können.
Also auf deinem Personal ausgeschaut.
Ach, da kennen wir keinen Match drauf.
Da gibt es so schöne Linien auf deinem Foto.
Die darauf hinweisen, dass dein Passwort schon mal digitalisiert wurde. Also die Datenbanken mit den Bildern, die haben die da.
Und auch die Bilder selbst, die bekommst du.
Eben, deswegen ja.
Gibt man nicht so da zwei ab?
Eben, eins für die Datenbank und eins für die andere Datenbank. Ich hab mir mal angeguckt, wie gut so Systeme sind, die so eineinige Zwillinge unterscheiden können. Gerade so bei Zutrittskontrollsystemen. Da ist es tatsächlich so, dass die so etwa 500 Gesichter in 5 Minuten rauswerfen können aus so Erkennungsströmen. Wenn die die Software ein bisschen modifizieren, dann halten die die Kamera an eine Menschenmenge, zoomen einmal quer durch so und die Gesichter, die heute erkannt werden, die ploppen dann gleich los.
Wo hast du dir sowas angeguckt? Wo hast du sowas gesehen?
Na, bei so einer Messe, wo Leute da banken waren und die haben halt auch so Leute das Security-Spielzeug gezeigt. Zeigen sie halt nur so semiöffentlich.
Es gibt unter anderem die Nummernschilder, die neu sind, auch deswegen so modifiziert. Mit diesen neuen Zahlen. Die sind einfach auch besser erkennbar.
Da hatten wir ja schon hier genannt, da gab es ja schon so eine Software. Die halten einfach nur noch die Kamera auf die Autobahn und dann ploppt einfach jeder Fahrzeughalter in dem Moment, wo er unter der Brücke durchfährt, ploppt er auch schon auf dem Bildschirm hoch. Das Argument war ja irgendwie, sind Fälschungs sicher, das ist das, was in die Medien getragen worden ist. Da sieht man auch wieder diese Formulierungen, auf die wir noch kommen werden, die immer dahinterstecken, um sowas durchzusetzen.
Also das Interessante an dieser eine Technologie war allerdings auch, das war eben eine bulgarische Firma, eine Osvlog-Firma und die hat die Software für unter 1000 Dollar dort angeboten. Das ist also wahrlich nicht nur für Sicherheitskräfte, sondern auch jeder Hobby, große Bruder irgendwie, kann sich mal kurz eine Videokarte in sein, all die PC stecken, dann irgendwie sich die Software aus dem Internet holen und ab ist.
Viel zu viel noch irgendwie die Daten an der Fahrt, aber zumindest Bewegungsprofile kann man schon mal noch stellen damit.
Na ja, wenn du nur ganz bestimmte Leute überwachen willst, auf die du es abgesehen hast, dann hast du ja die ihren Kennzeichen.
Zumindest kannst du einen Laptop auf einer Autobahndrücke montieren mit dem Solarpanel, irgendwie 3, 4, 5 Ausfallautobahnen um Berlin rum und dann weißt du einfach genau, wer in diese Stadt fährt und wer wieder rausfährt.
Also wenn wir sozusagen wissen wollen, wer sich im zukünftigen Regierungsviertel auffällt, brauchen wir noch eigentlich nur bei den entsprechenden, so viele sind es ja nicht, Ein- und Ausfahrten dieses räumigen Geländes Kameras zu montieren. Und dann können wir sozusagen bei entsprechenden Petitionseingaben uns unmittelbar immer an denjenigen wenden, der gerade angekommen ist.
Nur, dass wir sowas natürlich niemals tun wollen.
Also ist das illegal? Interessant ist, dass diese Nummernschilderkennungstechnologien werden schon bei amerikanischen Parkhäusern, mittlerweile auch bei deutschen Parkhäusern, serienmäßig verwendet, um zu kontrollieren, welche Fahrzeuge rein und raus fahren.
Tankstellen auch bestimmt auch.
Ja klar, die haben genug Kameras da hängen. Also bei den Parkhäusern, das ist in Amerika teilweise so, ich hab's auch schon in Skandinavien gesehen, dass sozusagen Leute, die den Parkplatz abonniert haben, die kamen dann halt da hin und hatten nichts, gar nichts so, nur ihr Nummernschild und dann ging die Schranke auf und sie konnten halt auf ihren Parkplatz fahren, ohne dass sie dann noch irgendwelche Zettel irgendwo reinstopfen mussten. Halt ist komfortabel, bequem, geht einfach, ist sicherer auch. Ist vor allem sicherer, genau.
Dann gibt's ja nicht nur Videoüberwachungen.
Genau, deswegen ist da nicht nur auch Audioüberwachungen.
Die wollen ja auch mithören, die Jungs.
Die wollen ja auch mithören, die Jungs. Und da gab's bis vor kurzem so eine Broschüre des BSI, ausgerechnet, also des Bundesamts für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik, die hieß Möglichkeiten für Lauschangriffe. Da ging es also darum, wie man sich als Wirtschaftsunternehmen davor schützen kann, dass man also zum Beispiel von der Konkurrenz eben abgelauscht wird. Seit der Einführung des großen Lauschangriffs heißt die Broschüre interessanterweise Möglichkeiten des illegalen Abhörens und Schutz davor. Also auf der CeBIT wurde sie schon unter diesem Titel verteilt. Die Grafik dazu mit den entsprechenden Symbolen findet ihr auf dem Web-Server. Die werden wir euch jetzt hier nicht runterlesen, weil das hier alles zu langweilig ist.
Also wer einen Browser zur Hand hat, kann jetzt mal schnell das www.cccde hüpfen. Nee, auf Chaosradio.ccde, Entschuldigung. Da liegt die Grafik sozusagen zum begleitenden Dokumentation bereit.
Tja, ach jetzt soll ich wieder die Musik hochziehen.
Ach schon, nee.
Vielleicht können wir das erst mal sortieren.
Zwei Sekunden nach dem Satz, das ist doch wieder total unprofessionell.
Später nach Durchgabe, ccc, Musik hoch.
Stimmt ja nicht.
Was gibt es Beschwerden? Ihr fliegt alle raus.
Ja, es ist kein etab auf dieser Seite von dem Pult.
Ihr solltet froh sein, dass ihr in dieser Station hier arbeitet.
Da können wir doch einen Hub mitbringen.
Stimmt, wir bringen einfach nicht mal einen Hub mit.
Wenn man sich die Umführe des BZG anguckt, zu den Überwachungsverfahrenen, bekommt man da durchaus kreative Anwendung von so etwas wie einer Antennenanlage, die auch eine Fernsehantennenanlage, die auch dazu dienen kann, sozusagen HF-Signale, also Hochfrequenzsignale von innen nach außen zu transportieren und nicht nur andersrum. Neben den sozusagen konventionellen Geschichten, so wie kleine Wanzen oder Stethoskope, die man irgendwie in Löcher durch Wände stöpselt oder was auch immer tut, gibt es noch so ein paar exotische Techniken, die, denke ich, erwähnenswert sind. Das eine ist vielleicht die Nummer mit dem Laserstrahl an die Glasscheibe.
Ja, die ist ja besonders beliebt und bekannt. Dabei geht es darum, die Glasscheibe schwingt ja sozusagen im Takt der Sprache, die im Raum gesprochen wird oder auch im Takt der Musik, die in dem Raum läuft. Und wenn man diese Schwingung rekonstruieren will, dann macht man es am besten, indem man den Laserstrahl auf die Scheibe richtet, die Reflexion dieses Laserstrahls auffängt und die Abweichung des Laserstrahls von der normalen und dann auch solche Geschichten wie Dopplereffekt und ähnliche Dinge auswertet, um die Sprache daraus zu rekonstruieren. Das gibt es mittlerweile in angenehm kompakter Bauformen, also muss man nicht mehr irgendwie große LKWs mit sich rumschleppen. Das sieht halt irgendwie so aus wie zwei Ferngläser in der großen Flasche.
Genau und nennt sich dann optische Mithöereinrichtung. Eine andere Leckerei ist natürlich der Transport von Daten von Computern bzw. die Ausnutzung der Abstrahlung von Computern bzw. von Kabeln zwischen Computern, also Serialverbindungen, Parallelverbindungen, Druckerkabel, Monitorgeschichten und so fort. Wobei es da nicht nur dieses Abhören von Monitoren gibt, was ja hinlänglich durch Presse, Rundung und Fernsehen schon mal irgendwo demonstriert wurde, sondern auch beispielsweise in der Nähe einer Heizung verlaufene Tastaturkabel, also zwischen Tastatur und PC, die es eben durch die Heizung auch möglich machen, überall im Gebäude, wo diese Heizung irgendwo mit ihren Rohren noch längs läuft, wieder aufzufangen und wieder lesbar zu machen.
Also das selbe kann man nämlich nicht noch mit Ethernet machen. Da gibt es so kleine Pinockel, die steckt man halt auf die Ethernet-Leitung rauf und dann hat man halt billiges Draht, wo sie sich anlässt. Nur, dass der Empfänger halt ein bisschen kostbilliger ist, macht sich gerade so bei Firmen Backbone sehr praktisch.
Und was haben wir dann hier noch? Achso, dann gibt es hier noch diese Geschichten mit der Powerline. Also das ist auch die Stromverbindung, die 220 Volt Verbindung dazu ausgenutzt werden kann, um da also noch ein paar Frequenzen durchzuschmuggeln. Da gibt es auch eine ganz zivile Anwendung, die Aktivierung von Straßenlaternen geschieht auf diese Art und Weise, dass also von der Stromeinspeise und der B-Wahlkehre da bestimmte Signale reingegeben zu bestimmten Uhrzeiten und eben die ganzen Laternen, die hängen alle an einer ganz normalen Leitung und haben eben so einen Empfänger und wissen, da kommt jetzt eine bestimmte Frequenz zusammen mit dem Strom und das heißt Anschalten oder eben Ausschalten.
Das primitive System, was man in Niederkorfhalle kaufen kann, sind halt diese Baby-Phones. Neulich habe ich festgestellt, mein Freund hatte so ein Baby-Phone und schloss das an und hörte plötzlich andere Dinge als die, die in seinem Kinderzimmer vorgingen. Da hatten dann offenbar noch jemand in dem Haus in der selben Strom-Strangleitung, genau dieselbe Sorte Baby-Tour-Baby-Phones, die dann halt kompatibel war. Interessant ist der Anfang von diesen Strom-Auswertungsgeschichten, war halt ne Aktion des britischen Geheimdienstes, die halt festgestellt haben, dass auf den Leitungen, die aus dem Verschlüsselungsraum der sowjetischen Botschaft in London kamen, dass da noch so ganz merkwürdige kleine Impulse drauf waren, die sozusagen der Klartext waren. Und dann haben sie halt einen relativ aufwendigen Empfänger gebaut und mit dem konnten sie dann halt den Klartext lesen, der auch neben dem verschlüsselten sozusagen unbeabsichtigt übertragen wurde auf den Kopperleitungen. Mhm.
Kommen wir mal zu einem Klassiker.
Der Telefonüberwachung. Da gab es ja gerade im letzten Jahr ein, zwei Veröffentlichungen, die uns sozusagen eine neue Dimension der Überwachung der Telekommunikation nahe gebracht haben, nämlich das Echelonsystem der amerikanischen NSL. Zu dem System selbst kommen wir jetzt sagen wir mal gleich so. Zunächst einmal hat sich da im Grundprinzip was geändert. Früher war Telefonüberwachung die gezielte Überwachung eines oder mehrere Anschlüsse einer oder mehrere Organisationen, Verdächtiger oder eben Befreundeter, Verfeindeter oder wie auch immer, Staaten, Stellen, Menschen. Heute wird das etwas anders gemacht. Man geht sozusagen dazu über alles zu überwachen. Alles heißt zunächst einmal alle Verbindungsdaten vor allem, sozusagen zu speichern, weil der telefoniert mit wem, ist zum einen hochinteressant und zum anderen ist es von der Datenmenge so beischaubar, dass man eben auch über Jahre hinaus das noch speichern kann und damit Kommunikationszusammenhängen nachzeichnen kann. Die andere Geschichte oder der andere Grund, warum das gemacht wird, ist, dass mittlerweile die Techniken der Spracherkennung, der Erkennung bestimmter Stichworte in gesprochenen Worten so weit fortgeschritten ist, dass es also praktikabel ist, alle Auslandstelefonleitungen der Bundesrepublik Deutschland beispielsweise durch eine Computerstation im bayerischen Bad Eibling, des amerikanischen NSA, durchzulauschen sozusagen und dort eben auf bestimmte Stichworte zu achten. Und diese Stichworte, wenn sie dann auftreffen, dann eben nochmal besonders nachzuhören.
Also die Auslandsleitungsabwehrstation steht bei Frankfurt nicht in Bad Eibling. Egal. Also diese Worten. Also es ist nämlich ein interessanter Fakt, dass alle Auslandsleitungen Deutschlands, wirklich alle in so einem kleinen Ort bei Frankfurt zusammenlaufen.
Was meint es mit alle, auch die von den anderen Telefongesellschaften?
Frankfurt ist der zentrale Hub für internationale Aufzeichnung.
Nicht mehr. Also das ist schon eine Zeit lang deswegen nicht mehr, weil einige Interkontinentalleitungen direkt von Hamburg ins Wasser gehen und einige Sachen auch direkt von München, also von Hintermünchen aus per Richtfunk in Länder wie zum Beispiel Italien gehen. Aber es ist egal, wir brauchen jetzt über die technischen Details uns hier nicht zu streiten. Wenn wir das mit dem Streiten machen, dann werden wir die Musik wieder hochdrehen, dann können sich dann die Hörer...
Im Chat kam gerade Zwischenfrage nach Handys.
Handys, Handys, kommen wir vielleicht ein bisschen später zu. Zunächst einmal geht es hier so ein bisschen um die Grundprinzipien. Und dieses Echelonsystem ist sozusagen das System schlechthin, kann man sagen. Also das ist auch so als Vorbildsystem für den Aufbau entsprechender nationaler Systeme mittlerweile dient sozusagen als Referenzmodell.
Also der amerikanische NSA hat halt schon seit mehreren zehn Jahren, kann man sagen, zusammen mit seinen Partnerdiensten in Australien, Neuseeland und Großbritannien angefangen ein vollständiges, flächendeckendes Abhörsystem für alle möglichen Arten von Kommunikation aufzubauen. Sei es elektronische Kommunikation, also Fax, Telex, E-Mail, sei es Sprachkommunikation über Telefon, sowohl über Richtfunk als auch über Kabel als auch über Satellit. Diese haben werden halt flächendeckend abgefangen, durch diese Wortbanken gepumpt und halt auf verdächtige Stichworte überprüft. Sei es sowohl bestimmte Anschlüsse, die halt sozusagen regelmäßig gemonitert werden als auch vorwiegend das halt sozusagen verdächtige Wortkombinationen, Namen, Ortsbezeichnungen, was auch immer, rausgefiltert werden und diese Gespräche dann sozusagen markiert werden für eine manuelle Auswertung, wo halt dann sozusagen dadurch selektiert werden kann, welche Gespräche eigentlich interessant sind. Also sind diese Lexika, die da verwendet werden, die werden halt von den Partnerdiensten sozusagen immer aufbereitet. Die NSA hat dann sozusagen das letzte Wort und die, also diese Rechner, die diese Spracherkennung machen, stehen jeweils an den Empfangsstationen von diesem Erlchnern-System. Und jeder Partnerdienst kann sozusagen Stichworte in diese Lexika von diesen Spracherkennern einspeisen.
Was konkret am Beispiel Bundesrepublik Deutschland heißt, der BND brüskelt sich ja auch gerne damit, dass er also in der Lage ist, auf bestimmte Stichworte, diese Wortbanken, einzusetzen. Das bedeutet also, der Bundesnachrichtendienst gibt der amerikanischen NSA die Stichworte, die sozusagen für ihn interessant sind. Die lauschen dann die Gespräche durch, stellen fest, wo was davon irgendwie vorkommt und dann überlegen sie sich, was sie den Deutschen geben und was nicht. Das ist sozusagen so, wie es de facto läuft. Und damit ist dann zum einen die technische Kompetenz des BND, oder sagen wir die Kompetenzsimulation des BND, sichergestellt, um also was weiß ich, den Giftgashandel mit Libyen oder was es auch immer gibt, ja zunächst einmal als Propaganda-Argument sozusagen sicherzustellen. Die andere Geschichte ist die, ich hab das selbst mal gesehen, aus einer amerikanischen Sicherheitskonferenz, wo eben auch so Dienstleister ihre Waren vorgestellt haben, eben diese Auswertung der Verbindungsdaten, also wer telefoniert mit wem, die oftmals viel interessanter sind als der Gesprächsinhalt selbst, was sich eben sehr schnell nachvollziehen lässt, wer mit wem in Kommunikation steht und auch wer mit wem in welcher Form von Kommunikationsbeziehung steht. Die Software, die dort also demonstriert wurde, war nicht nur dazu geeignet, durch so riesige Datenbanken von gespeicherten Verbindungsdaten zu gehen und dann also aufzuzeichnen, es handelt sich um eine Firma mit verschiedenen Filialen, es handelt sich um eine Mafia mit dem Paten ganz oben, den Unterpaten unten und den, was weiß ich, den Kurieren ganz unten oder ähnliches, sondern eben auch, wie sieht denn eine Freundschaft aus, wie sieht eine Familie aus, wie sieht eine Schulklasse aus, wie sehen die Kommunikationsverbindungen eines 20-Jährigen üblicherweise aus und so weiter und so fort, um also ja sozusagen großflächig und im Detail und im Jahre nach und nach im Zeitpunkt nachzuvollziehen, so können, wer steckt denn wie wo mit drin?
Vor einigen Jahren wurde mal beim als Handys noch lange nicht in jeder zweiten Hand oder bei manchen sogar in beiden Händen vorhanden waren, wurde damit geworben, dass ein Handy abhörsicher ist, also zumindest ein digitales. Nach dem C-Netz kam der digitale Netz in Europa GSM und da hieß es absolut abhörsicher. Da wurde aber nur ganz kurz mit geworben.
Ja, das ist auch im Prinzip eine totale Ente. Das hätte man sich auch schon vorher in dem Moment schon klar machen können, weil man kann ja mit einem Handy jeden Liebigen, normalen, nicht verschlüsselten Anschluss anrufen, ohne dass man da selber noch irgendeine Technik dazu ansetzen muss. Und das kommt ja da auch irgendwie unverschlüsselt abhörbar an. Also von daher geht das im Netz sowieso unverschlüsselt vorwärts. Bezog sich sozusagen im Wesentlichen auf diese Funkstrecke.
Also die zwischen dem Handy und der Base.
Genau, also die Verschlüsselung ab, der sozusagen da, wo die Antenne ist, die das Telefon, die Telefonsignale empfängt, ist sozusagen nicht mehr gegeben. Es ist im Gegenteil sogar so, dass die Richtfunkverbindungen bei allen deutschen Providern von den, also von den Base, dann auch nicht mal von den Base-Stations, sondern von den Mobilstationen zu den Mobile Switching Stations unverschlüsselte Richtfunkverbindungen sind, wo halt nichts weiter läuft als PCM-Kodierung. Das ist also keine Verschlüsselung, sondern nur ein Datenübertragungsstandard. Und es gibt halt etliche Geräte auf dem internationalen Markt zu kaufen, die genau diese Richtfunkverbindungen abschnorcheln können. Diese Richtfunkverbindungen sind halt klassisch sozusagen. Da braucht man irgendwie keine weiteren Besonderheiten beachten. Das Problem ist halt nur, dass man gerne wissen möchte, welche Telefonnummer man abhört. So, weil da über so eine Richtfunkverbindung sind halt 2 Megabit, da gehen halt so 30 Kanäle rüber oder sogar mehr in diesem Fall, in diesem Fall sogar 60, wenn nur 32 Kilobit benutzt werden. Und diese, die sind halt gleichzeitig drauf. Und man möchte ja gerne jemanden speziell abhören. So, ohne dass man jetzt zum Beispiel den Netzbetreiber damit belästigen muss, dass man dann Abhörgenehmigung braucht und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Was man also tun muss, ist rauskriegen, mit welcher Telefonnummer das Subjekt, was man nur abhören möchte, gerade telefoniert. Und da gibt es halt diesen sogenannten Imseacatcher, der ging vor einiger Zeit ein bisschen durch die Presse. Dabei erhalte es sich im Wesentlichen um ein Gerät, das kurz eingeschaltet wird, dafür sorgt, dass die Zellen, die eigentlich sozusagen die Telekommunikation sicherstellen, überlagert werden und alle händlichsten in der Umgebung sich bei diesem Imseacatcher versuchen einzubuchen.
Also mit anderen Worten das Ding tut so, als wäre es eine Vermittlungsstelle.
Genau, und dabei wird halt die netzinterne Identifikation aller dieser Rufnummern übermittelt, die da versuchen, sich einzubuchen. Und wenn man die dann hat, kann man halt entweder direkt die Funkverbindung weiter fortführen zur Zelle und auf dem sozusagen so eine Art mannense Mittelattack machen oder man treibt halt ein etwas mehr Aufwand und hört halt die Richtfunkverbindung von der Zelle zur Norway Switching Station ab.
Ich wollte das Ganze jetzt schon zusammenfassen, wenn du jetzt noch nicht da bist.
Nee, meine Frage geht jetzt wieder von den Handys weg auf normale Telefone. Es gibt ja auch diese Telefone, die so einen Scrambler drin haben.
Ja Moment, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Also ich wollte jetzt zunächst mal kurz zu deiner Ausgangsfrage, nämlich zur Abhörersicherheit von GSM. Also zum einen handelt es sich natürlich um Werbeargumente, klar. Zum anderen handelt es sich um sozusagen den ganz anfänglichen Stand der Implementierung. Und ja zum dritten ist es halt so, dass zum einen damit dieser IMSI-Catcher überhaupt eingesetzt werden kann, damit also ein Ding so tun kann, als ist es eine Funkzelle und das Handy sich darin einbucht, ist der Standard, der GSM-Standard, so sozusagen zurechtgeschraubt worden. Also da ist, wenn man es anders formulieren will, ein Sicherheitsloch drin. Und dieses Sicherheitsloch, das ist da mit Absicht drin, das ist da eben drin, um genau das zu gewährleisten, damit beispielsweise dieses Ding, das dann so tut, als ist es eine Zelle, den sogenannten Verschlüsselungsmodus 0 oder auch die unverschlüsselte Kommunikation zwischen Mobiltelefon und Zelle eben aktivieren kann und damit eben mit ganz primitiven technischen Funkmitteln halt abgehört werden kann.
Es gab vor 2, 3 Jahren gab es mal so einen Fernsehbericht, der recht putzig war zu dem Thema Standortbestimmung über ein Handy. Also dass das möglich ist, weiß glaube ich wahrscheinlich jeder. Und da gab es dann aber so ein, als das zum ersten Mal klar wurde, gab es einen Fernsehbericht darüber und das war putzig, sage ich deswegen, weil die haben dann so einen Raum gezeigt, wo man das also machen kann bei irgendeinem Netzbetreiber, der dann sagen kann, die Nummer befindet sich gerade da unter. Und dann haben sie aber wirklich so völlig blöd eigentlich gezeigt, dass dafür aber nur drei Leute einen Schlüssel haben für den Raum.
Fernsehen, Johnny, beziehe deine Information nicht aus dem Fernsehen. Fernsehen ist kein Informationsmedium, Fernsehen ist ein Unterhaltungsmedium. Denn nur deine Gehirnzelle in der Radio ist irgendwie, das kommt ein bisschen drauf an. Wir versuchen hier ja auch nicht unbedingt...
Wenn wir es in Fortainment machen.
In Fortainment, das ist ein ganz schön widerliches Wort.
Das finde ich ganz schön hart. Aber um nochmal kurz darauf zurückzukommen, also diese Anwendung, wo befindet sich ein Mobiltelefon, die ist ja nicht nur durch die Gesetze mittlerweile erschlossen, dazu kommen wir gleich noch ein bisschen in Gesetzesblock.
Die vor zwei, drei Jahren auch noch anders waren.
Sondern auch der Cebit gibt es auch mal über jene Menge Firmen, die sogenannte Telematik betreiben. Beispielsweise Firmen, die es also einen Mobiltelefoninhaber anbieten, dass er eine bestimmte Rufnummer wählt aus seinem Auto heraus. Dann weiß diese Firma automatisch, wo derjenige sich befindet, aufgrund eben der vom Netzbetreiber übermittelten Standortdaten und kann dann eben sagen, naja, da ist ein Verkehrsstau in deiner Nähe und der ist so und so lang und du fährst mal besser die nächste rechts ab und die zweite links und wie und was.
Wer macht das mit welcher Netzbetraube?
Die eins macht das derzeit, da ist es Tigaron und mannis, man macht das demnächst. Das ist halt so, du rufst da an und gibst halt nur auf der Handy-Tastatur ein, ob du gerade nach Norden, Süden, Osten oder Westen fährst, mehr brauchst du nicht zu tun, dann bekommst du per SMS oder per Anruf die...
Also das ist nicht mit GPS gekoppelt?
Nein, es ist einfach aufgrund der GSM-Verbindungstage.
Genau, also interessanterweise die...
Bei Damla macht das mit GPS.
Das ist aber ein anderes System.
Also hier geht es ja um ein kostenpflichtiges System für Leute, die eben nicht die 9000 Mark haben, um sich so ein Navigationsgerät ins Auto einzubauen, sondern die ein PIS-numales Mobiltelefon haben. Und die halt eine 190er Nummer ist ja klar, die lassen sich da schon was Kosten anwählen und dann eben entsprechend mit den Daten...
Also es funktioniert ja so, dass du halt einmal anrufst, das kostet nichts und dann pro Nachricht, die du bekommst, kassieren sie halt eine Mark auf deiner Telefonrechnung. Interessanterweise heißt die Gesellschaft, die diese Staudaten erhebt, und zwar unter anderem auch auf der Basis der teilnehmenden GSM-Teilnehmer. Also sozusagen die Mobiltelefon-Teilnehmer sind gleichzeitig, wenn sie da in diesem System mitmachen, sind sie auch sozusagen Stau-Ermittler. Selbst wenn sich das irgendwie in einer Weile nicht bewegt, wissen sie, steht im Stau und so. Diese Gesellschaft, die das betreibt, die wird von Mannesmann und Telekom und Debes gemeinsam betrieben. Und die heißt Deutsche Daten-Gewinnungsgesellschaft. Da habe ich mich echt geärgert, dass wir diesen Namen nicht vorher reserviert haben.
Ist aber auch klar, wenn Stau ist, fangen alle an zu telefonieren. Ich habe auch mal auf so einem Krisen-PR Seminar der Lufthansa gelernt, dass die also auch deswegen für die interne Kommunikation, für den Fall, dass an einem deutschen Flughafen was passiert, haben die Lufthansa-Mitarbeiter also alle im Zweifelsfall noch ein Zehnetz im Schrank liegen, weil sie genau wissen, dass die D-Netz-Zellen in dem Moment, wo an einem Flughafen etwas passiert, nur alle voll sind, weil die nur eine beschränkte Kapazität haben und Zehnetz benutzt eh keiner mehr. Und das ist halt sozusagen das Backup-System. Und im Zweifelsfall haben die alle dann auch noch einen City-Roof-Pager. Das hat zwar sonst auch kein Mensch mehr, aber das funktioniert im Zweifelsfall im Gegensatz zu dem digitalen Spielkreis.
Chaosradio im Blumen bei Fritz, jeden Mittwoch im Monat, außer dieses Mal. Es gibt übrigens keinen April Shards von uns. Ihr habt wahrscheinlich alle was super Tolles erwartet. Ähm, und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, machen wir gar nix.
Was macht dich da eigentlich so sicher, Johnny? Ich meine, hast du nicht das Gefühl, vielleicht eine ganz klugene Finte von uns aufzulegen?
Vielleicht ist ja die ganze Sendung April Shards.
Das lassen wir offen.
Das findet gar nicht statt. Ist vielleicht aufgezeichnet. Das hat gar nicht Platz.
Wir sind ein paar hirnlose Idioten, die an die Wand gestellt werden, als erstes.
Bis zum Fritz-Kurz-Info, reden wir noch ein bisschen über die Technik. Danach geht es dann los mit den Gesetzen, mit der Gesetzesseite der staatlichen Überwachung. Wir haben über Videoüberwachung geredet, über Audioüberwachung. Wir haben gerade ein bisschen über E-Mail-Überwachung geredet.
Handys geredet, Indie-Überwachung geredet. Alles wird überwacht.
Nur die Mikrofone hier hören uns nicht richtig ab, oder?
Hast du das auch gerade gehört?
Du hattest gerade einen Wackelantimm, oder?
Nee, hatten alle.
Die Mikros waren gerade alle aus, kurz.
Die Rolls-Ball-Taste.
Das ist eine tolle Erfindung. Wer noch nicht beim Radio war, findet das vielleicht nicht. Hier gibt es so eine schöne Tasse, steht drauf, Royce Bern.
Und wenn man die drückt, dann passiert genau... Super.
Sehr plastisch erläutert.
Was ich noch erzählen wollte, in Orwell 1984 gibt es ja dieses hübsche Konzept von den Rundfunkempfängern, die man nicht ausmachen kann. Und in einem Hotel irgendwo im Baltikum, also war da noch so ein richtig russisches Neubauhotel, da gab es so kleine Lautsprecher, die standen auf jedem Zimmer, so kleine viereckige Lautsprecher und die hatten so einen Potentiometer dran, da konnte man sie leise stillen, aber man konnte sie nicht ausmachen.
Was ist denn mit einem der großen Themen im Netz überhaupt mit E-Mail-Überwachung? Ich meine, es gibt ja Leute, die packen in ihre Signatur unten so die ganzen Stichworte hintereinander weg, um eventuelle Suchmaschinen zu verwirren. Also da kommen Stichworte wie Acid, LSD, Drogen, Sexüberfall, Sex, Porno rein.
Ja, wir hatten das ja eben schon mit Echolon. Also E-Mail wird überwacht. Alles, was nicht verschlüsselt ist, und sicherlich auch vieles von dem, was schon verschlüsselt ist, wird irgendwie untersucht. Absolut unbedingt ist eine andere Geschichte. Es werden da massenhaft Indizes aufgebaut, Logfiles mitgeschrieben, wie sich sozusagen einer überwachenden Instanz diese Datenmenge präsentiert. Kann jeder mal selber für sich ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Zum Beispiel, wenn man im Internet unter www.dejanews.com einfach mal die Newsarchive der letzten Jahre nachgeht, da ist es halt ganz interessant, wenn man so ein paar Netzpersönlichkeiten, die irgendwie schon seit 10 Jahren im Internet in irgendeiner Form teilnehmen, deren Namen dort eingibt, dann kriegt man also eine unglaubliche Liste von allen Diskussionsbeiträgen, die die halt in den letzten 10 Jahren jemals zu irgendeinem Thema in einer Newsgroup abgelassen sind.
Inklusiv ihre Jugend zünden.
Und genau solche Profite zu erstellen, dass es mittlerweile for the masses ist.
Ja, nur fragt man sich natürlich trotzdem, auch wenn es nur ASCII ist, es ist ja trotzdem nicht wenig. Der gesamte E-Mail-Datenverkehr wird ja nicht weniger. Und eine reine Suchmaschine nach Stichwörtern sucht es natürlich völlig albern.
Naja, die suchen ja nicht so im Nachhinein, sondern sie suchen ja im Prinzip in Echtzeit. In dem Moment, wo die Daten vorbeigucken, gucken sie sich die an. Die NSA, der gehören auch große Teile der Infrastruktur des Internets in den USA, was ja eigentlich nach wie vor auch noch die Kerninfrastruktur des Internets an sich ist. Auch wenn wir hier mittlerweile schon einiges selber haben, aber vieles läuft halt über die USA.
Interessanterweise über Virginia, also alle großen Internetprovider haben ihre Zentrale in Virginia, wo halt auch die NSA ihre Zentrale hat. Wenn irgendjemand behauptet, das Internet wäre die Zentrale, dann lügt das schlicht und ergreift.
Stellt sich trotzdem die Frage, ob denn in Zeiten, in denen ja auch eine E-Mail-Absende-Adresse nicht mehr unbedingt die sein muss, die drauf steht, wie ist da die Beweislade zum Schluss?
Es gibt natürlich anonyme E-Mailer und es gibt allerlei Möglichkeiten, sich da eher als bei einem Sprachmitspeicherungssystem davor zu schützen, erkannt zu werden. Aber es geht hier auch überhaupt nicht darum, etwas zu beweisen, sondern es geht hier schlicht und ergreifend darum, also Personeneinzugrenzungen, Einschätzungen zu gewinnen. Und die Amerikaner verteidigen das mitunter auch ganz offensiv unter dem Motto, naja, wir wollen halt die Überwachung starten. Und zwar immer dann, wenn man ihnen den Vorwurf macht, sie würden ja in Wirklichkeit nur Wirtschaftsspionage betreiben. Es kommt also immer gerade drauf an, wer ihnen jeweils den Vorwurf macht, warum sie denn diese Systeme betreiben. Gegen bei der deutschen Regierung wurde mir berichtet, oder vielmehr gut, gegenüber einem Vertreter der deutschen Regierung hat sie als Sonderbeauftragte der amerikanischen Regierung für die Kryptoregulierung mal so feiern gelassen. Na klar geht es um den Überwachungsstart, klar geht es uns gerade um die kleinen Fische, um die vielen kleinen Elemente, die eben eine Gesellschaft in unserem Zeitalter so schwierig handhabbar und regierbar machen. Und die kriegt man halt im Zweifelsfall zunächst einmal verdachtsmäßig und dann gibt es ja so bestimmte Zusammenhänge wie Drogen oder...
Aber das klingt doch eigentlich ein bisschen... Also ich meine, wenn du sagst, dass die sagen, es geht um die kleinen Fische, das macht doch eigentlich nicht besonders viel Sinn, diesen technischen Aufwand zu treiben, um jetzt sagen wir mal, zum Beispiel einen kleinen Drogendealer zu fassen. Der macht ja das Land nicht unregierbar.
Aber 60.000 Drogendealer machen ein Land einigermaßen unregierbar.
Tun sie auch nicht.
Na wenn du dir Kalifornien anguckst zum Beispiel, die haben da schon erhebliche Probleme damit. Das Problem ist halt, dass diese Prohibitionshaltung der Gesellschaft, bzw. nicht der Gesellschaft, sondern des Staates an sich der halt irgendwie sein Prohibitionsmonopro bewahren will, halt tatsächlich mit derartigen Techniken relativ einfach zu bewahren ist. Weil je weiter die Techniken entwickelt werden, desto einfacher ist es auch Klangkriminelle zu handeln. Letztendlich ist das eine Kostensenkung, wenn du halt den kleinen Dealer auf der Straße nicht mehr dadurch ermitteln musst, dass du da irgendwie wohl langstiegst oder langklatschen. Sondern wenn du einfach sein Telefon überwachst und weißt, ok, jetzt krieg ich da gerade eine Lieferung, da brauchen wir was hin zum Zuschlagen.
Also ich stell mir nur vor, dass es ja durchaus auch für den Staat Sinn macht, dass es den Staat nicht nur unregierbar macht, wenn Kleinkriminelle irgendwie das machen, was sie machen, sondern im Gegenteil, die sind dann halt auch in einer Ecke, wo man sie auch wieder besser kontrollieren kann, wahrscheinlich.
Ja du machst, sobald du merkst, dass halt bestimmte Dinge überwacht werden, tust du ja Sachen nicht mehr. Also das Problem, was ja auch von der EU erkannt wurde, ist ja tatsächlich, dass du, wenn du weißt, dass du überwacht wirst, dann handelst du nicht mehr frei. Oder wenn du auch nur weißt, dass du überwacht werden könntest, dann handelst du nicht mehr frei. Sowohl was jetzt die kleinkriminellen Handlungen betrifft, aber auch vor allen Dingen, was zum Beispiel missliebige politische Ansichten betrifft. Das war das Konzept, was in der DDR wirksam war, dass halt irgendwie klar war, dass in jeder Opposition unsere Gruppe sind halt spitzeldrin so.
Und damit fällt Terrorismus einfach aus.
Ja, sicherlich.
Es ist die Kreativität, sich auf legale Aktionsformen im Zweifelsfall oder sich halt nicht erwischen zu lassen. Aber zunächst einmal, es gibt ja auch sogenannte...
Es wird sicher alles schwieriger, so viel steht fest.
Es gibt ja auch sogenannte Aufstandsbekämpfungstechniken. Das ist so eine eigene Wissenschaft für sich, wo es eben auch gezielt darum geht, gerade in Krisenfällen bestimmte Bevölkerungsschichten anzugehen. Jetzt wird beispielsweise gerade die Telekommunikationssicherstellungs... nee, das Telekommunikationssicherstellungsgesetz durchgesetzt. Das heißt, dass auch in den neuen GSM-Mobiltelefonnetzen und auch bei den neuen Service-Providern dieses Konzept durchgesetzt wird, dass also im Falle eines Krisen- oder Katastrophenfalls alle Telefonanschlüsse zunächst einmal nicht mehr in der Lage sind, selbst tätig zu telefonieren. Die können maximal noch angerufen werden. Nur bestimmte Leute können also aufgrund einer Whitelist, einer eben mit sondern berechtigten List überhaupt noch telefonieren. Das sind so Geschichtchen, die da so im Hintergrund passieren und im Zweifelsfall mal kurz eine Krise zu produzieren, um dann also, ja, keine Ahnung, was man da so tun kann. Oder nehmen wir mal an, irgendein Kernkraftwerk fliegt uns jetzt um die Ohren. Dann ist natürlich damit zu rechnen, dass bestimmte subversive linke Elemente versuchen werden, irgendwie sinnvoll, irgendwie hier, ja, keine Ahnung, irgendwas vielleicht auf die Beine zu kriegen. Die muss man natürlich vorbeugen.
Mehr zum Thema Gesetze nach dem gleich vorigen Fritz Kurzinfo. Chaosradio Imblemon bei Fritz. Es geht um Überwachung im Allgemeinen und im Detail. Wir haben uns mit der Technik beschäftigt jetzt eine gute Stunde lang. Und gleich nach dem Fritz-Kurzinfo werden wir uns mit der Gesetzeslage auseinandersetzen.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
23 Uhr 31.
Ritual. Die Bemühungen für ein Bündnis für Meliastellen sind zunächst gescheitert. Bei einem Treffen von Bildungsminister Rütkos mit Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften gab es keine Ergebnisse. Nach Angaben der Gewerkschaften werden im Herbst mindestens 70.000 zusätzliche Lehrstellen gebraucht. Prognose. Der Autoverkehr in der Region Berlin Brandenburg wird weiter zunehmen. Gleichzeitig verliert der öffentliche Nahverkehr Fahrgäste. Des Gittes nun Gutachten des Deutschen Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung hervor. Das Institut forderte dem Berliner Senat auf, seine Verkehrspolitik zu überdenken. Störfall. Wegen eines Lexem-Q-Systems ist ein Reaktor des Atomkraftwerks Ignalina in Litauen abgeschaltet worden. Es sei aber keine Radioaktivität ausgetreten, erklärten die Betreiber. Zwischenfall. Unmittelbar vor dem Halbfinalspiel der Champions League zwischen Real Madrid und Borussia Dortmund kam es am Abend im Stadion von Madrid zu einem Eklat. Fans des gastgebenden Teams rissen Verbindungsstangen ein und brachten so eines der Tore zum Einsturz. Dadurch begann das Spiel erst 45 Minuten, verzeihung 75 Minuten später. Im zweiten Halbfinale besiegte Juventus Thüringen den AS Monaco mit 4 zu 1. In dieser Nacht im Fritz-Wadeland zeitweise Regen, Abkühlung auf 6 bis 10 Grad, morgen weiterhin Regen, dann 8 bis 15 Grad.
Verkehr.
Einige Baustellenmeldungen zunächst A2 Hannover Richtung Berlin zwischen Wohlin und Brandenburg bis früh um 2. Verkehrsbehinderungen wegen Brückenbauarbeiten A10, Dreigesprieher Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen der Leme und Königs-Wusterhausen bis 1 Uhr Bauarbeiten und Berlin Autobahn 111 Charlottenburg Richtung Uranienburg Sperrung der Richtungsverbahn zwischen Holzhauser Straße und Weidmannsbrüster Damm wegen Bauarbeiten im Tunnel Tegel Ortskern bis früh um 5 Uhr, Umleitung hier ausgeschildert.
Zunächst Fritz Kurzinfo mit Matthias Karcov.
Chaos Radio, Kurzmeldung, USA. Nachdem die Welt sich langsam darauf verständigt hat, dass in zwei Jahren der eine oder andere Computer ein Problem mit dem Datum haben wird und Backups und frühzeitige Bankabhebungen vom CCC empfohlen werden, geht nun ein neues Gespenst um. Der New Yorker Börsenindex Dow Jones segelt derzeit boomend der 10.000er Marke entgegen. Software-Experten berichten allerdings davon, dass einige Spekulanten-Software den Sprung schlecht mitmachen wird, da sie auf die zusätzliche fünfte Ziffer nicht vorbereitet sind. Zumindest die Beruhigungspillenindustrie braucht sich wohl in nächsten Jahren keine Gedanken um ihren Umsatz machen. Auckland, New Zealand Die Firma Mercury Energy in New Zealand war über einen Monat damit beschäftigt, die vollständig zusammengebrochene Stromversorgung der Innenstadt von Auckland wieder auf die Beine zu bekommen. Die 40 Jahre alten Stromkabel hatten die Waffen gestreckt, nachdem ihnen Sugar Baby El Nino mit einer anhaltenden Dürre den Rest gegeben hatte. Unter den Betroffenen waren Banken, Krankenhäuser, die Börse und die meisten Unternehmen des Stadtzentrums. Notstromaggregate konnten nur das Schlimmste verhindern und gehören darüber hinaus zu den gefragtesten Artikeln. Zwischenzeitige Reparaturerfolge des Versorgers wurden regelmäßig durch die Wiederinbetriebnahme von Kühlschränken sabotiert. Dallas, Texas. Die Erstauststrahlung eines digitalen HTTV-Fernsehsignals in Dallas hatte ungewünschte Risiken und Nebenwirkungen. Im Baylor University Medical Center verweigerten augenblicklich 12 EKG-Geräte den Dienst. Die Geräte stammen noch aus den 80ern und sollten eigentlich schon längst ausgetauscht werden. Die Fernsehausstrahlung wurde umgehend eingestellt, zumal es ohnehin noch keine passenden Empfangsgeräte zu erwerben gibt. Land der unbegrenzten Unmöglichkeiten. Einem Forscher-Team ist es nun erstmals gelungen, einen Prototypen eines Quantencomputers zu bauen und in Betrieb zu nehmen. Die Maschine ist in der Lage, besonders große Zahlen in Windows-Eile zu faktorisieren. Zu Demonstrationszwecken wurden bereits eine DES-4 verschlüsselte Nachricht dekodiert. Präsident Clinton gratulierte den Forschern, aber kündigte an, dass er ein Gesetz auf den Weg bringen werde, das den illegalen Export von Quarks aus dem Gebiet der Vereinigten Staaten verbietet, bis ein System geschaffen ist, das Quark-Hinterlegungen ermöglicht und jedem Quark im Universum eine eindeutige Kennzifffahrt zuweist. Bitte?
Wollt nicht abhören.
Wir sind hier in einer Radio-Sendung, da wird nicht telefoniert.
Ja, aber wenn Johnny während der Radio-Sendung pro Laden geht, dann kann ich wohl auch telefonieren. In drei Stunden muss man am Abend ein Mikrofon im Klo anbringen, Johnny.
Aber erst, wenn ich hier einen Internetanschluss hab.
Nächstes Mal bringe ich hier einen Hab mit.
Ob das so interessant für uns ist.
Dann können wir sozusagen das Klo-Mikrofon direkt ins Internet senden.
Ich erinnere mich an irgendeine Szene in einem Film mit Leslie Nielsen.
Ja, das Wort von der Redeheld mit einem drahtlosen Mikro und dann kurz zwischen...
Aber das ist ein ziemlich schamatischer Film, weil das die nackte Kanone oder irgendwie so ein grossartiges Film.
Das war richtig schlecht.
Apropos, richtig schlecht.
Richtig schlecht werden kann einem, wenn man sich reinzieht, was sozusagen im Rahmen der sogenannten Telekommunikationsliberalisierung das gerade an neuen Gesetzen erwartet. Es gab ja auch schon vorher Einschränkungen des Brief- und Fernmeldegeheimnisses, so beispielsweise in der Version von 1989, wo es heißt, zur Abwehr von drohenden Gefahren für die freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung. Den Rest des Absetzes erspare ich euch bis auf das Ende, das da lautet, sind die Verfassungsschutzbehörden des Bundes und der Länder das Amt für den Militärischen Abschirmdienst und der Bundesnachrichtendienst berechtigt, den Briefpost oder Fernmeldegeheimnis unterliegende Sendung zu öffnen und einzusehen, sowie den Fernmeldeverkehr zu bewachen und aufzuzeichnen. Hier ist also nicht unbedingt von einer fallbezogenen Vorgehensweise die Rede, sondern wie gesagt zur Abwehr von drohenden Gefahren und so fort. Die neuen Gesetze oder das neue Telekommunikationsgesetz geht da erstmal vom Prinzip ganz anders ran. Das ist ja jetzt so, dass jeder sozusagen Telekommunikation betreiben darf, nicht mehr nur die Telekom allein. Allerdings muss er dazu vom Staat eine Lizenz erwerben. Und diese Lizenz ist eben geknüpft an vielfältige Bedingungen. Es ist also nicht unbedingt so, dass Liberalisierung heißt. Die Wirtschaft kann jetzt machen, was sie will. Und der Staat, der hat so ein paar Rahmenbedingungen noch festgeschrieben. Sondern der Staat ist derjenige, der eine Lizenz erteilt oder eben verweigert und die Bedingungen dafür auch ganz genau festklopft. Und das, was in diesem Telekommunikationsgesetz an Befugnissen drin ist, ist weitaus mehr, als es bisher an Einschränkungen des Brief- und Fernmelding-Einwesens gab. Und da sind dann diese Nettigkeiten eingebaut, wie eben beispielsweise das Auskunftsersuchen der Sicherheitsbehörden im automatisierten Verfahren. Um also das erklären zu können, muss ich zunächst mal einige Begriffe erklären. Wir haben das gestern in unserer internen Dienstags Weiterbildungsrunde versucht. Und wir sind da immer an dieses eine Wort gestoßen, an dem sich alle irgendwie gerieben haben und gesagt haben, was war das jetzt? Und deswegen, also um es zu übersetzen, der große Bruder heißt jetzt Bedarfsträger. Und der Bedarfsträger ist laut dem Paragraph 90 des neuen Telekommunikationsgesetzes oder vielmehr die Bedarfsträger. Das ist also das Zollkriminalamt, der Bundesnachrichtendienst, der Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, die Bundeskriminalämter und so weiter und so fort. Zu den einzelnen Diensten erzählen wir vielleicht nachher noch, was wir in der Zeit haben. Berechtigt über die sogenannte Regulierungsbehörde, die jetzt also das ehemalige Bundespostministerium sozusagen nachbildet oder nacherbt, berechtigt in die Kundendateien all derjenigen, die Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen für andere geschäftlich erbringen, reinzugucken. Und in diesen Kundendateien muss mindestens stehen, also Name, Anschrift und Rufnummer bzw. Rufnummerkondigente bzw. Adressen bzw. Adresskondigente. Es kann ja auch nicht um einen Internet-Service, wobei da handelt, da haben die Kunden natürlich keine Rufnummer, sondern eben eine Adresse oder eine IP-Nummer oder was auch immer.
Du darfst das ruhig nochmal wiederholen. Also in Kurzform, die Kundendaten dürfen direkt, ohne dass der Service-Probeider da für was weiß, angesogen werden.
Der Trick an diesem Gesetz besteht nämlich eigentlich darin, dass derjenige, der diese Kundendatei führt, also von diesen Abfragen nicht Kenntnis erlangen darf. Das ist ihm bei Strafe verboten. Das ist eine der höchsten Strafhandlungen, die überhaupt in diesen Gesetzen drin ist. Wenn also jemand, der Telekommunikation betreibt, sagen wir mal die Telekom, nehmen wir sie mal als Beispiel. Wenn die also dann Mitarbeiter kann mich nicht leiden und hört sich deswegen in meine Leitung rein, dann ist das ein Verstoß gegen das fernweite Geheimnis, dann ist da eine bestimmte Strafhandlung in diesem Gesetz drin. Wenn aber der Staat beschließt, mich abzuhören mit richterlichem Beschluss oder durch den Verfassungsschutz und ein Telekom Mitarbeiter steckt mir das, der sagt mir, hey, hör mal zu, da ist er auf deiner Leitung und so weiter und so fort, dann ist die Strafe, die den erwartet, wesentlich höher als die, die ihn erwartet, wenn er mich abhört. Nämlich? Das geht bis zu fünf Jahre Knast. Und das andere sind bis zu zwei Jahre, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf hab. Das muss ich aber nochmal nachschlagen, das sind die, ne? Schieß mich durch.
Das Interessante dabei ist, dass der technische Aufwand, der getrieben werden muss, um diesen Sachen nachzukommen, ist zum Beispiel für Internetprovider, wo jeder, der sich über einen Modem einloggt, irgendwie dynamischen IP-Adresse zugewiesen bekommt, natürlich erheblich so. Der muss halt tatsächlich massive Investitionen begehen, um halt diesen Auflagen nachzukommen.
Wobei jetzt ein Internet-Service-Provider noch nicht zwangsläufig unter das TKG fällt.
Ja, und das ist sozusagen der nächste strittige Punkt. In diesem Telekommunikationsgesetz sind eben ganz viele Sachen drin festgehalten, wie eben das die Durchsetzung von Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die Geheimhaltungspflicht mit Netzbetreibern usw. usf. Und im Moment ist noch ein bisschen strittig, wer eigentlich darunter fällt. Wenn jetzt unser Lieblingsprovider SNAFU in Berlin zum Beispiel nicht nur wie bisher normale analog Standleitungen haben will, sondern von der Telekom mal einen ganz unvermittelten Zweitrad haben will, um darüber, sagen wir mal, ADSL zu machen, 34 Megabit oder irgendwas über normal Zweitrad-Kupfer, was technisch geht, aber voraussetzt, dass die Telekom da nicht irgendwelche schwachmatischen Filter einbaut, nicht irgendwelche Spulen draufsetzt, die böse Dinge tun oder was auch immer, dann bräuchte SNAFU um das zu tun, eine Anerkennung nach TKG. Und um diese Anerkennung zu haben, muss er also die ganzen Auflagen erfüllen und um die Auflagen zu erfüllen, muss er dann wiederum auch seine Kundendatei ins Web stellen und so weiter und so fort. Und da auch diese Regulierungsbehörde...
Nicht ins Web stellen.
Nein, nicht ins Web, ins Netz stellen.
Er muss die Technik bereichstellen.
Man muss natürlich die technische Seite auch selber finanzieren. Was da wieder der Jungser zahlt?
Und da die Situation ist im Moment absurderweise die, dass diese Regulierungsbehörde, wie Sie schon formuliert haben, die gibt es zwar formal juristisch schon, die sitzt allerdings aus provisorischen Gebäudegründen im Moment in zwei verschiedenen Städten, weil das eigentliche Gebäude, in dem sie sitzen soll, wird gerade noch gebaut. Und das heißt, dass es sozusagen diese Abfragestellung für diese Datenbank von der Seite der Regulierungsbehörde auch erst zur Hälfte gibt. Und das heißt, dass man im Moment eine solche Anerkennung nach TGHG erst mal irgendwie bekommt, die sagen, naja, geht schon irgendwie so vorläufig und so weiter und so fort. Langfristig heißt das, dass sozusagen in dieser Telekommunikationswelt es Konzerne 1. und 2. Klasse geben wird. Die Konzerne 1. Klasse, das sind die ganz großen, so wie Mannesmann, Arquo, Ortello und wie sie alle heißen, die sich also leisten werden können, diese ganzen staatlichen Befugnisse zu erfüllen. Und die anderen, das sind so die Internet-Service-Provider, die etwas kleineren, die sich das alles nur so bedingt erlauben können. Ja, die sind sozusagen die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen, man könnte das Ganze auch Lizenz-Erpressung nennen, sagen wir mal, die sind an einem Hebel. Und dieser Hebel, der kann im Servicefall eben umgelegt werden, wenn da mal jemand im Innenministerium einen schlechten Tag hat und sagt, also eigentlich stinkt uns das doch, diese dezentralen kleinen Provider, die wir nicht überschauen können und die uns irgendwie in ihre Kundendateien erst reingucken lassen, wenn wir vorbeikommen und überhaupt, naja.
Also, um deinen nicht enden wollenden Redefluss mal kurz was entgegenzusetzen, wir sind sozusagen immer noch beim TKG.
Genau, beim Telekommunikationsgesetz.
Telekommunikation, das ist bereits verabschiedet, das ist alles gültig und da.
Es gibt es immer noch die Geschichte mit dem Werk, geschäftsmäßig Telekommunikation erbringt. Ein Krankenhaus beispielsweise, das seinen Patienten die Möglichkeit bietet, während ihres Aufenthalts ein eigenes Telefon am Bett zu haben, mit vielleicht Telefonguthabenkarten, wie man es in Berlin auch oft hat, dann eben raustelefonieren zu können, eine eigene Rufnummer zu haben, erbringt per juristischer Definition Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen geschäftsmäßig für andere.
Eine Firma, die......die so viel heißt, dass das Krankenhaus seine Kunden-Datenbank online zur Verfügung stellen muss, zur Abfrage.
Genau, und von diesen Abfragen nicht Kenntnis gelangen darf, und die technischen Stellen ist so definiert, dass also ganz entspannt die vollständige Kunden-Datei mehrmals täglich irgendwie, zwei für zwei, kann also im Minutenrhythmus festgestellt werden, wer dann jetzt im Krankenhaus gerade irgendwie ein Telefon und ein Bett bezogen hat, und wer es wieder abgemeldet hat, und wer also wo gerade Telekommunikationsanschlüsse hat. Und das Ganze ist eben so herrlich unüberschaubar. Also auch eine Firma, die beispielsweise von ihren Angestellten verlangt, dass diese Privatgespräche selbst bezahlen, erbringt so die juristische Definition, Telekommunikationsdienstleistung geschäftsmäßig für andere. Und auch die müssen dann ihre in Anführungszeichen Kunden-Datei, bzw. eben ihre Mitarbeiter-Datei entsprechend abfrageberechtigt dort den Stellen zur Verfügung stellen. All das sind Sachen, die jetzt gerade aufgebaut werden, die nach einem etwas problematischen Umfeld für eine demokratische Gesellschaft reden.
Könnte etwas schwierig werden.
Wir können das ja auch erstmal sacken lassen.
Genau, wir können das erstmal sacken lassen, weil die Musik für die E-Rad wieder besser ist.
So, liebe Kinder und Kinderinnen, ihr könnt jetzt anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Warum sagt das überhaupt? Das wird doch alles hier abgehört automatisch.
Die Fritz Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Ganz besonders motivierend ist immer, wenn jemand im Chat die Frage stellt, die gerade äußerst lange erläutert worden ist. Tippen, Lesen und dabei noch zuhören. Multitasking ist eigentlich nicht so richtig schwer. Ihr könnt anrufen, wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema Überwachung, zum Thema Abhören habt und wir versuchen, die hier zu beantworten. Tim, was haste denn? Wolltest du was sagen?
Jetzt gerade weg.
Ich hab dich gar erst angedrückt.
Ich bin so scheu und schüchtern.
So, dann machen wir das Spiel mit der Telefonartung.
Ja, ich hab eine Frage und zwar, ich hab mir jetzt eine Fernsehkarte gekauft und die ist intercast-fähig. Das heißt, ich kann mir Informationen zu dem entsprechenden Sender internetmäßig runterladen. Ja, ist das irgendwie abhörsicher oder?
Das war eine tolle Idee, Hörer reinzunehmen.
Also, was du da beschreibt ist einfach, das ist doch diese Intel Fernsehkarte, oder?
Das Thema heute Überwachungsstaat hatten.
Ich meine, du empfängst Fernsehsignale, das hören alle ab.
Warte mal, ich verstehe gerade die Verwirrung nicht. Du findest die Frage doof oder was?
Ich dachte, was hat die mit dem Thema zu tun?
Ja, insofern, wenn er diese Karte installiert und die Sorge hat, dass die eventuell nicht nur empfängt, sondern auch senden könnte und ob die abhörsicher ist, dann ist das wirklich gar nicht blöde Frage.
Du willst sozusagen wissen, ob jemand feststellen kann, dass du Fernsehen kursierst?
Nein, ob jemand feststellen kann, was er auf dem Rechner hat zum Beispiel.
Ist denn diese Karte so gebaut, dass man damit was senden kann? Dass es nur mal mehr Informationen empfangen, oder nicht?
Also Intercast ist nichts weiter als eine Abwandlung von komprimierten HTML, eine Austauschlücke, was dann statt der Videotext gesendet wird. Und da ist halt ein Webbrowser dahinter, der dafür adaptiert ist. Und wenn du halt auf eine URL klickst, die sozusagen im Videotext ist, wirst du halt auf einer Internetseite gefolgt. Gibt es halt nichts anderes, als wenn du tatsächlich irgendwie hingehen würdest und in deinem Webbrowser irgendwie über als einen gibst. Genau so abhörsicher oder wenig abhörsicher ist es auch.
Ihr seid total demotivierend. Ich fand die Frage nicht blöd.
Na ja, aber sagen wir es mal so, wenn ich mir die Frage stelle, ob mich jemand abhören kann oder nicht, dann denke ich, geht es auch immer ein bisschen um bestimmte Formen von Daten. Es geht um die Privatsphäre der Informationsgesellschaft.
Die unter Umständen in seinem Rechner durchaus.
Du denkst ja auch, dass du die ganze Technologie schon ausüben kannst.
Hey, lass uns lieber nicht rumlabern. Okay, aber wir können ja bei der Gelegenheit...
Ja, aber der Punkt ist einfach...
Nein, der Punkt ist...
Nein, der Punkt ist einfach, in dem Moment, wo der erste der Anruf gleich behandelt wird, als ob er eine blöde Frage stellt, sind hier sofort alle Leitungen wieder weg.
Und du vergraulst unsere Hörer an.
Und wenn er sich...
Was ist denn der Platz für ein Rest des Konzeptes?
Und wenn er sich... Nein.
Jetzt schlag ich zurück.
Ich finde, wenn jemand euch als Experten fragt...
Ich bin mal die Orangensaftblatt drauf.
Ich finde, wenn jemand euch als Experten fragt, dann hab ich da was gekauft, was okay ist oder nicht. Also nur dran einzelne Post, am 70 97 110.
Garantiert ohne Anmache.
Ohne Anmache.
Eine Geschichte, die ein privater Robin Hood hier vorgeführt hat, war diese kompromittierende Emission bei Monitoren einmal etwas anders. Nämlich besteht auch die Möglichkeit, im Monitorsignal sozusagen Sachen zu verstecken, so wie dieses System hier funktioniert, sozusagen in der Austauschluke des Fernsehprogramms, Daten zu verstecken. So kann man das auch bei VGA oder sonstigen Monitoren machen und damit eben sozusagen Daten rausschmuggeln. Das heißt, dass man eben die Möglichkeit hat, was weiß ich, ein throianisches Fiat und ein kleines Hinterprogramm zu installieren. Das zum Beispiel den gesamten Inhalt der Festplatte zyklisch sozusagen in die entsprechenden Bildgeschichten reinhaut und dann eben mit entsprechender Abhörvorrichtung, aber die ist dann eben schon irgendwo in der Nähe räumlich zu postieren. Also man kann schon davon ausgehen, das werden sie nicht bei jedem Erdenbürger machen.
Andy versucht das gerade aus seiner Art zu entschuldigen.
Ich versuch das sozusagen sinnvoll einzubetten, weil ich denke, das gibt ja ein Anpaul, das hat vielleicht einen gewissen belustigenden Faktor. Aber dazu gibt es ja auch diese Taste. Woran das denn in aller...
Ah, da ist keiner drauf...
.machen kann.
Was ich mal schade finde, ist, dass kein lautes Piepertönt, wenn man diese Taste drückt.
Das kann man mal einführen.
Jetzt nimm mal die Finger von der...
Nein, die Tasten hier.
Nein, der will jetzt die Tasten drücken. Johnny, wir müssen jetzt hier was...
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaos Radio. Wie man hört.
Ja, hallo, hier ist der Christian, was ist das?
Hi, Christian.
Ja, wir sind entspannt jetzt.
Einmal frei, cool.
Wir hatten sozusagen keine Frage, sondern wir warten auf welche.
Wir warten eigentlich auf Fragen von euch.
Vielleicht rufst du nachher noch mal an, wenn du genau weißt, worüber wir reden.
Also Tim, du vergraulst die Gehörer mit unbeantwortlichen Kommentaren.
Das geht nicht an. Bei Christian war's okay.
In aller Höflichkeit wissen, was die Frage ist und du Pauls ihn an.
Ich hab ihn auch angepault.
Können wir nicht mal eine Rolls-Royce-Taste nur für Andi einziehen?
Hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da? Ja, wer bist denn du?
Moment, ich bin dabei. Ist das richtig, dass es heute über das Internet geht?
Ja, ganz genau. Und zwar, weil wir von dir wissen, was hast du für einen durchschnittlichen Datendurchsatz?
32 Wits pro Sekunde.
Alles klar. Danke dir. So, dann haben wir ja noch... Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Meinst du mich? Grüß dich. Und grüße die Karoten. Kennt ihr den kleinen Artikel aus dem Freitag? Kleine PDS-Anfrage an die sächsische Landesregierung. Darf der Bürger eine entdeckt elektronische Wanze mit dem Hammerbreit schlagen?
Ja, das war die Antwort.
Antwort. Steffen Heidmann, sächsischer Justizminister und beinahe Bundespräsident, antwortet, technische Einrichtungen, die nach dem Entwurf der Gesetze zur Änderung des Grundgesetzes und zur Verbesserung der Bekämpfung der organisierten Kriminalität nach entsprechender richterlicher Anordnung zum Abhören und aufzeichnen, dass nicht öffentlich gesprochenen Wortes in Wohnungen installiert werden können, bleiben in der Regel Eigentum der installierenden Stelle. Ihre vorsätzliche Zerstörung kann daher als Sachbeschädigung strafbar sein.
Man hätte also auch Nein sagen können.
Also ich weiß, das ist interessant, da könnte man auch richtig drüber streiten, weil eigentlich ist eine Wanze ja tatsächlich in diesem Augenblick zwar nicht in meinem Eigentum, aber in meinem Besitz. Und was mein Besitz ist, darf ich erstmal irgendwie behandeln, wie ich will.
Mhh, das stimmt nicht.
Also ich find's ihm wird genial.
Also ich meine, wenn da nicht irgendwie ein Bundesadler mit Do Not Destroy drauf ist, wieso darf ich dann eigentlich rauftreten?
Na, weil du zum Beispiel alle anderen Dinge, die dir nur überlassen werden, ja auch nicht zerstören darfst.
Interessant ist irgendwie, dass wahrscheinlich da kein kleiner Bundesad da drauf ist. Insofern wäre ich nicht in der Wutigen Industrie schon da.
Da steht bestimmt auch keine Service-Nummer drunter und die Frage wäre zum Beispiel, ob die Haftpflichtversicherung so was dann übernimmt.
Aber, Frage über Frage.
Äh, dank dir erstmal.
Alkoholisiert, aber Spaß dabei.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hier ist nochmal der Christian aus Dessau.
Nochmal Christian.
Ah, so eine coole Aktion eben, oder? Da hast du jetzt eine Antwort. Was? Eine Antwort, ne? Eigentlich nicht. Ich find's nur cool, wie ihr da hinter euer Mikrofon abfeiert und die Leute hier so richtig schön abserviert. Ist cool, oder?
Ja, das machen wir eigentlich gar nicht.
An den Schaltern so zu sitzen, ist nicht schlecht.
Christian, du kannst gar nicht sagen, was immer du willst. Du bist auf Sendung. Blöd ist nur, wenn jemand anruft und sagt, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich anrufe, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das Thema ist. Ich hab euch auch nicht zugehört. Den wurde einfach rausgeschmissen.
Das ist mir eigentlich auch real, weil ich will einfach nur mal kurz zum Radio sein.
Okay und Tschüss.
Okay, Tschüss. So, 7097110 ist die Nummer in Potsdam. Hat der gerade noch so zum Ende des ersten Aprils geschafft. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Nix?
Keiner mehr? Wer ist denn da? Hallo?
Ja, hallo, ich bin Andreas aus Berlin.
Andreas, hi, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ja und zwar ich hab mal eine Frage so, Thema Sicherheit und Internet. Ich hab ja ziemlich viel in letzter Zeit gelesen über diesen PGP Schlüssel, halt wo, der Kanter und so gegen sagt, naja wollen wir nicht, ist uns nicht recht. Aber ich seh die Sache andererseits auch so, vielleicht haben so abhörende Institutionen schon irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, gerade an diesen Schlüssel ranzukommen. Also so, gerade dass die wollen, dass es verbreitet wird, damit der Bürger das Gefühl kriegt, naja PGP ist sicher, kann ich nehmen.
Na speziell, da geht die Diskussion noch ein bisschen tiefer, denn das war bisher, also das war bis zur, glaube ich, jetzigen Version relativ unmöglich, aber da könnt ihr wahrscheinlich genähert und genauer zu sein.
In gewissen Sinne hat er da gerade ins Schwarze getroffen, weil die Firma PGP ist gerade von dem ursprünglichen Erfinder für Zimmermann verkauft worden an eine Firma, die heißt Network Associates und die Firma Network Associates wiederum gehört einer anderen Firma, die heißt Network General und der Lebenslauf der Firma, also das Geschäftsführer der Firma Network General ist sozusagen äußerst aufschlussreich. Der Mann war sehr lange bei der NSA, also beim amerikanischen Geheimdienst und ähnliche nette Sachen. Und was da gerade abgeht, die Amerikaner nennen das Endorsement. Das heißt also, dass sozusagen der Name PGP nun mehr dazu benutzt wird, um also aller Welt den Eindruck zu vermitteln, weiterhin sei alles in Ordnung. Das ist sozusagen eine schon etwas schwerwiegendere Situation, weil wenn Leute gar nicht verschlüsseln, dann wissen sie wenigstens, naja, das ist alles unsicher, ich könnte abgehört werden, ich schreibe mal lieber nichts Belastendes rein. Wenn Leute aber glauben, sich zu schützen, indem sie irgendwie einen sozusagen Schloss benutzen, das aber gar keins ist in Wirklichkeit, dann neigen sie natürlich viel eher dazu, da irgendwelche Sachen reinzuschreiben. Insofern, bei PGP geht das gerade ziemlich ab und das kann man demnächst wahrscheinlich vergessen. Was es geben wird, ist Open-PGP. Es gibt sozusagen eine freige, es wird demnächst eine freie, nicht kommerzielle Version von PGP geben, die sozusagen nach wie vor nach diesen Richtlinien, also offener Source Code, kein Key Recovery, kein Corporate Message Recovery und diese ganzen netten Features, die die Regierungsstellen da gerne drin hätten, geben wird. Und dann wird, naja, hoffentlich, endlich, alt, bald wieder alles gut.
Wie sieht es denn da aus mit alten PGP Versionen?
262 kann man denke ich problemlos noch empfehlen. Bei 5.0 ist es ein bisschen das Problem, auf der einen Seite ist es endlich mal eine anständige Benutzeroberfläche, auch nicht computerfreaks können, dass irgendwie einigermaßen chimpanzenkompatibel, um dieses böse Wort zu benutzen, irgendwie bedienen. Ist halt für sozusagen grafische Benutzeroberflächen irgendwie entsprechend implementiert. Das Problem ist, dass da noch einige, sagen wir mal, minder komfortable Features drin sind, die wahrscheinlich dann in PGP 6.0 ganz toll behoben sind, aber dafür dann eben auch den Nachschlüssel.
Das Kernproblem, das Kernproblem bei PGP, mit dieser Versionsproblematik gerade ist das, die 2.6 Version von PGP hat halt verschlüsselt nach dem sogenannten RSA-Verfahren. Das ist halt das, was eigentlich bisher immer verwendet wurde und alle PGP-Schlüssel, die da draußen sind, sind in der Regel RSA-Schlüssel. Also PGP ist das Programm und die Verschlüsselungsmethode, die verwendet wird, das ist diese RSA-Methode. Die Firma PGP will aber jetzt keine Lizenzgebühren mehr zahlen an die Firma RSA, die daran hält. Das verfällt übrigens in zwei Jahren, also von daher ist es eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig. Es geht letztlich um was anderes. Auf jeden Fall haben die jetzt eine andere Verschlüsselungsmethode genommen, die im Prinzip genauso funktioniert, aber eben anders ist. Heißt DSS. Das ist schon durchaus noch dasselbe Prinzip, aber es ist halt einfach ein anderer Algorithmus, ein anderer Schlüssel. Da sind einfach ein paar bits anderses Detailkram. Es geht nur darum, dass sie sozusagen an RSA dafür keine Lizenz zahlen müssen. Es ist halt ein bisschen anders. Und es ist sozusagen offiziell dokumentiert und hat auch das Zeug Internetstandards.
Was mich halt gewundert hat, ist, dass trotzdem ja dieses Exportverbot aus USA bestanden hat. Dass es aber halt, dass halt der Quelltext veröffentlicht wurde, dass es halt hintenrum trotzdem publik wurde. Und das ist für mich doch irgendwie so eine gefakte Sicherheit. Also so ein vorgetäuschtes Gefühl, wo ich mir gerade sage, so eine Institution wie der NSA oder so, wo eigentlich keiner richtig weiß, was die machen und wo die ihre Programmierer dahinter haben, dass die da halt schon längst ihre Finger drin haben.
Na gut, die NSA versucht halt gerade auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise den Griff, den PGP, den Griff zu bekommen. Das war das, was Andi gerade erzählt hat. Aber das Mitte der Exportgeschichte ist eigentlich noch erst rein. Das ist ja eigentlich nur der Versuch, dieses sinnlose Exportverbot zu umgehen. Denn es gibt da gesetzliche Entscheidungen in den USA, die eben sagen, wenn das gedruckt auf Papier außer Landes geht, dann ist das sozusagen ein Buch und ein Buch fällt unter Meinungsfreiheit. Das finden ja die Amerikaner ganz toll. Also Freedom of Speech, das Buch darf also problemlos, auch der Source Code exportiert werden, das haben die dann getan. Also sie haben es ausgedruckt, exportiert und dann haben sich irgendwelche Leute da in Europa hingesetzt, irgendwie Stück für Stück wieder eingescannt, also ob sie es wirklich getan haben. Zumindest ist es so die offizielle Darstellung und haben sozusagen denselben Code wieder zum Laufen bekommen. Dieses Re-Engineering verkauft mittlerweile die Firma PGP sozusagen aus Norwegen jetzt auch in den europäischen Raum. Andere Firmen machen das auch, aus Belgien und so weiter. Das ist nur der Versuch, die amerikanische Regierung ein bisschen in die Knie zu zwingen, die auch genau weiß, dass sie da eigentlich gar nichts gegen tun kann. Aber mit diesem ganzen Aufwand, der getrieben werden muss, verzögert sie die Sache zumindest so weit, dass sie die Möglichkeit hat, über andere Maßnahmen da wieder rein zu hacken. Und das ist derzeit das Rennen, was da stattfindet, ist natürlich super undurchsichtig für jemanden, der da nur ein bisschen am Rande da steht. Von daher war die Frage jetzt auch wirklich sehr passend. Internet, also es gibt da zahlreiche Mailing-Listen, in die man sich eintragen kann, zum Beispiel die Krypto-Mailing-Liste. Ich poste das einfach mit dem Chaosradio-Ticker. Falls du da eingetragen bist, dann kriegst du das sozusagen.
Hast du einen Internetzugang, Andreas?
Ich kann es nochmal kurz ansagen, auch für alle. Es gibt den Chaosradio-Ticker, das ist sozusagen unsere Ankündigungs- und Feedback-Mailing-Liste. Wer sich da eintragen lässt, der kriegt vor der Sendung eine Ankündigungs-Mail und danach auch das entsprechende Feedback und diese Krypto-Geschichte werde ich da auch noch mit reinnehmen.
Und am besten so alle Adressen und den ganzen Kram findet man am schnellsten bei chaosradio.ccc.de Genau, das sind auch die Archive von den alten Tickersachen, wer das noch nicht gekriegt hat. Man kann da auch die Links zu alten Sendungen finden, die kann man nämlich über Real Audio bei Fritz abrufen und alles wunderschöne Geschichten. Also das ist eigentlich die beste Anlaufstelle, da steht auch unsere E-Mail hier. Andreas, dank dir. Wie viele Leute sind eigentlich auf dem Ticker drauf gerade?
Also wir nähern uns der Tausender Marke.
Super.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Der war aber Handgefluchten.
Ich möchte immer noch mal jemanden kennenlernen, der Faxe singen kann. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, Attila, aber ich kann keine Faxe singen.
Das macht nichts, du kannst trotzdem Fragen stellen.
Ja, die Frage ist ICQ. So ein Programm, womit man sich im Internet als anwesend melden kann. Die Frage ist, ob bekannt ist, wer dahinter steckt und wer die Daten nutzt über dieses preisgegebene Wissen.
Ich bin, ich weiß, welche Software du meinst, aber ich kenne die jetzt nicht genau. Das ist die Software, wo man sich zentral, glaube ich, bei dem Server der Firma bucht, man sich da sozusagen ein.
Nein, ich bin jetzt online und dann kann man sich... Das funktioniert automatisch. Normalerweise würde man sowas ja über die IP machen, da die aber jetzt immer, also bei den meisten, die uns dann dynamisch ist, vergibt dieses Programm dir irgendwie, sobald du dich mit deinem Internet Service Provider verbindest, du hast eine eigene Kennnummer, also sozusagen noch mal so ungefähr wie eine extra IP.
Bei der Firma?
Nee, einfach in dem Moment, wo du einloggst.
Nee, nee, das muss ja wieder erkennbar sein.
Das ist wie ein IRC-Server.
Genau.
Ich glaube, der Server läuft derzeit wohl noch bei der Firma. Also das ist sozusagen, da wo der Server ist, da muss ich ja irgendwo anmelden. In dem Moment, wo dein Computer sich irgendwie hochfährt und du im Internet drin bist, dann wird das Programm automatisch aktiv, sagt ich bin hier und das wird halt zentral gesammelt. Und naja, also kann es mal schwer davon ausgehen, wenn die Leute da irgendwie nach ihrer E-Mail-Adresse, ich weiß nicht genau, was man da alles angeben muss, aber alles was da angegeben wird, das verkaufen die unter Garantie nach hinten raus, weil in den USA haben sie damit gar keine Probleme.
Die Frage ist ja zum Beispiel halt die Verbindung mit diesen anonymen Remailern, dass dann einige zum Beispiel auch von der NSA, CIA oder wer da halt immer hinterstecken soll, betrieben werden angeblich und das dann halt hinter solchen Firmen eventuell auch so jemand steckt. War die Frage, ob da irgendwo auf dieser Mailing-Liste sowas zu hören war?
Diese Frage wird halt gerade auf dieser Krypto-Mailing-Liste heftig diskutiert. Da gibt es natürlich die verschiedensten Ansichten dazu. Einige sind mittlerweile der Meinung, dass irgendwie klar ist, dass der eine oder andere Remailer von der CIA betrieben wird. Es ist halt so, dass bei diesen Chained-Remailern, also sozusagen eine Kette von Remailern, benutzt wird, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es zu einer Kompromittierung kommt, relativ gering ist, solange tatsächlich so ein Nächsten-Diagnostik-Cypher-Pan-Remailer benutzt wird, die halt tatsächlich alle Sachen zwischen den Remailern verschlüsseln und sozusagen in mehreren Schichten ein- und auspacken kann.
Ist denn ICQ schon mal da irgendwo aufgetaucht als Stichwort? Ich hab bei so Sachen immer den Ahnung, also Paranoia immer schön und gut, aber ich hab bei gerade Geschichten wie ICQ schon oft den Ahnung, dass das erst mal Software ist, die jemand geschrieben hat, weil er sich dachte, ich hab ne prima Idee, wie man das Internet noch mal ein bisschen voller machen kann. Keine Frage, aber ich hab das erst mal erfolgreich gemacht. Ja, und wenn es erfolgreich ist, ich glaub dann sind, also ich hab davon auch noch nichts gehört, dass da irgendwelche, dass man da um die Ecke denken muss, wer sich darum gekümmert hat. Was ich mir aber durchaus vorstellen kann, ist sowas, dass es natürlich ganz simpel kommerziell genutzt wird, um Benutzerprofile zu erstellen, einfach für Firmen, die verkaufen wollen.
Das ist ja auch kein Sicherheitstool, sondern ein Remailer sozusagen, der natürlich besondere Obachtung hat.
Das ICQ ist ja sozusagen nur dieses, ich bin jetzt auch im Internet, also im Prinzip ist es eine Funktionalität, die Online-Dienste halten.
Du kannst aber da natürlich schöne Statistiken führen und so Profile anlegen, wie oft benutzen die Leute wann, das Internet und so weiter.
Es gibt auch unter verschiedenen Namen, es gibt auch People Talk, das macht genau dasselbe.
Die Frage ist halt immer nur, was bei solchen proprietären Programmen übertragen wird, ob wirklich nur dieses Hallo, ich bin hier übertragen wird, ob da noch andere Daten rübergehen, wobei, da war es mal selbstbewusst, am Anfang bei 95 selber... Naja, 486er auf Gates-Plattform.
Also wenn du jetzt einen Macintosh gehabt hättest, hätte ich dir einen guten Tipp geben können, für die Leute, die vielleicht einen Macintosh haben, es gibt ein schönes Programm, es heißt Stream Watcher und das kann man einfach starten und der gibt einfach alles in schönen großen Fenstern aus, was das Programm gerade raus sendet im Klartext, wobei natürlich dieser Klartext einem auch nicht unbedingt immer weiterhilft.
Und die Frage ist ob Stream Watcher nicht eventuell...
Also dann kann man sich noch einen Rechner dahinter hängen mit Isopieck, dann kann man...
Ich glaube der einfachste Weg wäre, die Kiste auch woanders hinzustellen.
Genau, Internet ist die Blütze, ne?
Ja die Frage ist immer nicht, ob man paranoid ist, sondern ob man paranoid genug ist.
Stimmt. Und ob es, wenn man nicht paranoid ist, ob es dann heißt, dass sie nicht in deinem Heer sind. Ne, umgekehrt. Na scheißegal, weißt du, was ich meine? Setz dich mit uns her. Wie heißt es? Nur weil du paranoid bist, heißt das nicht, dass du nicht hinter die Großmannsfäden hast?
Heißt das nicht, dass du nicht mal die Musik hochdrehen darfst?
Ne, mach ich nicht. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Anton, hallo.
Ich hab eine Frage, ob ich mich als Mac-User da in mehr Sicherheit wiegen kann, dass wenn jetzt zum Beispiel eine Mail von mir abgefangen wird, und die auf die Idee kommen, meine Platte zu durchstöbern oder so.
Nein, das kann ja sowieso keiner einfach so. Also ich mein, da muss man auch mal ein bisschen die Bremse anziehen.
Die E-Mail-Virus, wenn du das jetzt gerade angesprochen hast, wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe, vergiss es einfach. Das ist der Hype schlechthin. Da gibt es immer wieder Leute, die darauf reinfallen.
Einstager sind aber immer ganz stolz drauf.
Ja, tatsächlich gab es auch mal Fälle. Und zwar in so integrierten Systemen wie Lotus Notes, wo das alles so miteinander verflochten ist, dass Programme und E-Mails Dokumente enthalten, die auch automatisch geöffnet werden. Und da ist es vorgekommen, da gab es diesen dokumentierten Pfeil. Aber das Ding ist einfach so populär im Internet, in der Regel, wo du von Plattform zu Plattform verschickst und nicht weißt, was der andere hat, ist so ein System im Prinzip Kram. Es gibt kaum Mailsysteme, die irgendwie solche Systeme haben.
Oh doch, die Microsoft Mailsysteme sind da...
Da wollte ich gerade nach dem Koma weiter reden, aber du darfst es gerne ausführen.
Es ist ja so, dass diese Microsoft Mailsysteme haben ja die hübsche Eigenschaft, dass sie ziemlich integriert sind in die Office-Umgebung, die da ist und es gibt zum Beispiel halt ein Makrovirus, der unter bestimmten Voraussetzungen, wenn er geöffnet wird, so ein Wortdokument, was als Attachment angefügt wird, mit Doppelklick geöffnet im Word. Im Word wird ein Makro ausgeführt, das die Adressdaten des E-Mail-Programms ausliest und dieses Dokument nochmal an, also mit dem es sozusagen gekommen ist, nochmal an alle Adressaten sendet, die halt in diesem E-Mail-Verzeichnis drinstehen.
Also für dieses scheiß Word hätten wir ihn eigentlich gleich noch eine Torte geben sollen.
Also für Firmen, die diese Software einsetzen, kann man sozusagen vollständig mit einer einzigen E-Mail infizieren, die halt ein Word-Attachment hat. Also sozusagen Word-Attachments durch die Gegendwelt, hier ist der was schon.
Okay, also es gibt doch E-Mail-Viren.
Gut, aber jetzt nochmal auf Antons Frage zurückzukommen. Es geht dabei nicht darum, wenn jemand deine E-Mail lesen kann. Da ist es völlig egal, welches System du fährst, weil deine Mail befindet sich ja im Netz und da, ja gut.
Jaja, nee, ich meinte nur, ob wenn er die jetzt liest und darin zum Beispiel irgendwas sich befindet, dass er auf die Idee kommt, dass meine Platte zum Beispiel jetzt nicht voller Raubkopien ist oder so. Und dass er sich da dann irgendwie sich haben kann, dass er da, weiß ich nicht, bevor da irgendetwas anderes hochfahren muss oder so.
Also ich höre da das andere große Ding, was immer wieder zitiert wird, heraus. Also es gab ja mal diesen Fall, als Windows 95 rauskam, wollte Microsoft damit ja auch sein eigenes Netzwerk, damals noch als Konkurrenz zum Internet, rausbringen, Microsoft-Network. Da gab es einen sogenannten Registration Wizard, ein Programm, das, wenn man das startet, wählte sich in MSN ein und registrierte sozusagen die Windows 95 Kopie gleichzeitig mit dem Benutzer in diesem Netzwerk und hat eben nachgewiesenermaßen zusätzlich auch noch ein Inhaltsverzeichnis von einer Festplatte mit übertragen, weil sie das halt einfach interessiert hat. Das ist relativ früh aufgeflogen, noch in der Beta-Version, das haben sie dann Polter-die-Polter natürlich wieder rausgehauen, aber das hängt ihr natürlich auch heute noch nach zurecht. Das war das. Das war glaube ich so in etwa das, wo es her kam. Ansonsten, so auf dem Mac ist das halt alles nicht so faschistoid, wie das irgendwie unter Windows teilweise der Fall ist. Das war's.
Ihr könnt weiter anrufen unter 031 der Potsdam, 70 97 110, Fragen zum Überwachungsstart stellen. Was mich immer wirklich verwundert ist, dass ihr jetzt mit so Kleinigkeiten kommt. Ich finde, dass das eigentlich eine ziemlich große Diskussion ist, die auch eher eine inhaltliche als eine technische ist. Also was ich zum Beispiel immer höre, wenn die Diskussion so unter Freunden oder Bekannten oder so in die Richtung geht, dann geht es immer erst mal los mit, was regt ihr euch denn darüber so auf? Ich habe nichts zu verbergen, von mir aus kann ruhig jemand meine Mail lesen, weil da steht ja nichts Kriminelles drin oder so. Und diese Diskussion, die würde mich schonen, dass die nicht auftaucht. Aber ich sage einfach mal so, dass das wahrscheinlich genau ein Zeichen für das ist, was passiert. Ich erinnere mich an die Volkszählung, wo es riesen Aufschreie gab überall und wo sich eine Menge Leute gegen gewehrt haben. Jetzt gibt es das Stichwort großer Lauschangriff. Da gibt es ein paar Zeitungen, die mal was drüber schreiben. Dann gibt es einige Leute, die mit den Schultern zucken und sagen na ja, aber so richtig Aufschrei in der Bevölkerung kann man das alles nicht nennen. Und scheinbar ist das jetzt einfach nur ein Spiegelbild davon, dass die Leute vielleicht entweder kein Interesse daran haben oder dass sie nicht interessiert oder sie einfach aufgegeben haben. Keine Ahnung.
Oder den Leuten einfach mittlerweile klar gemacht wird durch verschiedene Einflüsse, dass das für sie irgendwie gut ist. Oder so.
Das ist natürlich auch noch eine Möglichkeit. An dem wage ich ja immer gar nicht zu glauben.
Ja hallo, hier ist der Martin.
Martin, hallo.
Mich würde mal interessieren, wie ist das mit Arztdaten, Diagnosen von irgendwelchen Sachen oder Zusammenhang mit Krankenkassen und so. Wie werden die wohin weitergemeldet und wie ist das mit Geheimdiensten?
Wir haben dir gerade nicht zugehört. Entschuldige, wir hatten hier gerade eine kurze Diskussion. Kannst du das bitte noch mal sagen?
Entschuldige.
Ja, die ganze Sache Arztdiagnosen, Daten, irgendwelche Krankheiten und so. Wo wird das hingemeldet, was muss der einzelne Arzt, was gibt er ab an Datensätzen, wendet er an Krankenkassen? Wie kriegen die Geheimdienste davon Spitz und so was?
Ja, frag mal dein Arzt. Ich meine, der wird dir genau sagen, was er da wohin melden muss. Also es gibt halt offiziell natürlich irgendwie einen relativ weitgehenden Schutz für diese Art von Daten. Es gibt halt bestimmte Krankheiten, die sind halt in Deutschland meldpflichtig. Aus solchen rechtlichen Gründen, also so was weiß ich zum Beispiel, Mülzbrand oder sowas, das ist meldpflichtig. Und ansonsten ist es halt so, dass eigentlich die Daten, die halt im medizinischen Bereich anfallen, zu den höchsten datenschutzrechtlichen Schutz in Deutschland genießen. Was dann tatsächlich in der Realität passiert, naja, das ist irgendwie schwer nachzuvollziehen. Meistens sind die Ärzte schon damit überfordert, irgendwie die Patientenkarte richtig rum, irgendwie da reinzustecken in ihren Chipkartenleser.
Ich meine, ComArts wird dir eine vernünfte Auskunft darüber geben wollen und können nur deine Daten hingehen.
Da wird sie in einem PC mit sicherer, amerikanischer Geldsoftware speichern und natürlich in einem abstrahlgeschützten PC nur verschlüsselt mit allerhöchster Sicherheitssoftware über Telefonleitungen übertragen. Auf gar keinen Fall wird er eine leicht verschlossene Praxistür haben und im Übrigen wird er auch nicht auf die Idee kommen, vielleicht seine Abrechnung mal zu Hause auf seinem PC zu machen und sich dazu den ganzen Shutter auch noch mal zu Hause auf die Platte zu spielen.
Da muss man aber ein bisschen, wenn du mit deinem Arzt, ich weiß nicht, wie dein Verhältnis ist zu deinem Arzt, aber wenn das, das gibt es halt coole Ärzte, die einem da ziemlich viel Information geben können. Es gibt übrigens auch eine Menge Ärzte, die Daten nicht übermitteln. Also zum Beispiel bei Aids-Tests, die ja irgendwie auch mit Namen eingeschickt werden teilweise. Es gibt Ärzte, die machen das getrennt und arbeiten mit Labors zusammen, die das alles anonym bearbeiten.
Ja, also das Problem ist, ich hab noch nicht mal so viel Sorgen bei Ärzten, aber bei der weitergehenden Verarbeitung, was dann die Krankenkassen betrifft, was passiert, wo stellen die Krankenkassen ihre Daten hin, inwieweit sind die von irgendwelchen externen Leuten abzufragen und so weiter.
Das ist, muss ich leider sagen, nicht so sehr unser Thema gerade. Wir wollten ja noch auf ein paar andere Sachen kommen. Wir würden das gerne jetzt ausführlich noch darlegen, wir sind da jetzt wieder ausreichend vorbereitet, was jetzt diesen Krankenkassenkram betrifft noch, wollten wir da jetzt schwerpunktmäßig drauf kommen.
Nee, ich verstehe die Vorgehensweise manchmal nicht, aber macht mal weiter, ihr wolltest zu dem Thema vorher noch irgendwas sagen? Also ich finde, das war ein durchaus wichtiger Teil dieser ganzen Abhörgeschichte.
Aber wir waren ja deshalb beim Überwachungsstaat.
Ja, es ist ja kein Abhören, wenn der Arzt...
Nein, es ging um die Frage, ob diese Daten, die ja vorhanden sind, eventuell auch noch von anderen abgehört werden können.
Also zu dem Thema kann man eigentlich mal wieder eine Meldung aus der letzten Woche zitieren, wo ein 16-Jähriger verurteilt wurde, der in irgendwo in Amiland regelmäßig die Verschreibungsdaten von Apotheken einfach nachts mit Mode im Daumen geloadet hat, weil die halt in keinster Weise verschlüsselt waren. Die hatten halt einen kleinen PC stehen, der halt nachts die Bestellungen an die Pharmaunternehmen übermittelte. Und da konnte man dann halt ein paar Spielereien komplett die Verschreibungslisten rausbekommen. Den haben sie irgendwie zu berichtig, sogar ein bisschen knastverurteilt. Aber er meinte, es wäre nicht besonders schwierig gewesen.
Also es gibt da verschiedene Sachen. Man kann halt immer so diese Sicherheitsdiskussion. Ist denn das jetzt sicher? Also erst mal, wenn Daten erfasst werden, dann werden sie gespeichert. Wenn sie gespeichert werden, dann werden sie erst mal so schnell nicht gelöscht. Wenn sie irgendwie lange auf irgendwelchen Datenträgern rumlegen, dann werden sie auch irgendwo hinkopiert. Und irgendwann verliert sich das. Und wenn jemand da ran möchte, dann kommt er da ran. Das ist einfach grundsätzlich so. Da muss man nicht über irgendwelche Systeme und Verschlüsselungstechniken reden. Wenn es die Daten erstmal gibt, dann sind die bei Bedarf und in entsprechenden Machtausübungen einfach immer da. Die Frage ist grundsätzlich, werden die überhaupt erst mal erhoben oder nicht? Das ist so das Problem. Und jetzt kommen wir in diese Kartenwelt und dieses, ich speicher alles auf meinem Chip, auf meinem Ring. Und alles liegt in der Datenbank. Und es muss ja irgendwie easy, lean, Management in den Behörden sein. Und alles mit Computern und toll. Die kriegen ein echtes Problem. Und wir kriegen damit natürlich auch ein echtes Problem. Nicht nur 2000, sondern vor allem danach. Datamining ist heutzutage ein Thema. Das könnte man auf der CeBIT überall sehen. Software, wir flügen durch ihren Datenbestand. Kaufhäuser haben irgendwie Einkaufsdaten von, und hatten ja alle schon diese Profilgeschichte. Und das gilt natürlich auch für die medizinischen Bereichen. Ich denke, da werden wir auch noch einige Schruten erleben. Also, Entschuldigung, für uns ist das manchmal immer schon gar kein Thema mehr. Ich verstehe, dass man das auch teilweise anders sieht. Aber die Diskussion ist einfach durch. Das ist einfach schon mal grundsätzlich ein Problem, wenn etwas gespeichert wird. Und unser Schwerpunkt heute ist halt der, was ist das Interesse des Staates? Auf welche Art und Weise nimmt er jetzt konkret Einfluss und versucht, in der Kommunikation zu bleiben, obwohl er auf der anderen Seite, wie wir ja sehen, durch diese Globalisierungstrends immer mehr gezwungen wird, eigentlich seine Hoheit aufzugeben? Heute ist ja so ein Staat Deutschland, wenn Herr Schröder an die Macht kommt, dann kann er sich freuen, dass er irgendwie seine eigenen Klüngeln und Klicken da jetzt etablieren kann, wo Kohl gewirtschaftet hat. Dadurch wird sich nicht sehr viel ändern, weil letzten Endes hängt er genauso in diesen ganzen Strom von Abhängigkeiten der internationalen Gesetze, die im Wesentlichen Wirtschaftseinflüsse sind heutzutage.
Also ich würde gerne noch mal auf die Frage kommen, die du vorhin gestellt hast, ich habe doch nichts zu verbergen. Das ist natürlich die Antwort bzw. das Argument, das man am häufigsten hört bei dieser Diskussion. Das ist einfach nur eine Frage, wie genau man nachfragt, ob man tatsächlich nichts zu verbergen hat. Und die meisten Leute bilden sich tatsächlich an, sie haben nichts zu verbergen. Bis sie vielleicht sich die Sache mal aus der Perspektive eines Geheimdienstes angucken, der aus irgendeinem vollkommen abseitigen Grund Interesse an ihnen haben könnte. Oder man könnte auch zum Beispiel darüber nachdenken, was die Leute da machen, wenn sie halt abhören, um auch zum Beispiel Kleinkriminelle zu fangen, ist natürlich automatische Verdachtsgenerierung. Sie wollen gerne Profile gewinnen, aus denen sie halt Daten generieren können, die ihnen sagen, okay, mit irgendwie 98%iger Wahrscheinlichkeit hat Herr Schröder oder was weiß ich, was wie auch immer heißt, irgendwie Beziehung zu einem Drogendealer, weil der telefoniert hoffentlich da und dahin und so immer, samstags, abends, wenn gerade sein Koks alle sein könnte. Und schon ist man irgendwie, nur weil man samstags abends seine kranke Tante anruft, irgendwie im Visier von irgendeinem komischen Drogenfahnder. Also diese Unfälle, die bei diesen Fahndungen passieren können, sind schon mal ein sehr wesentlicher Punkt, weil ausschließend lassen sie sich nie. Und die andere Frage, die sich da für mich stellt, ist so, wieso wird das überhaupt betrieben eigentlich? Also man muss ja nicht fragen, ich kann es doch erdulden, ich habe ja schließlich nichts zu verbarren. Die Frage lautet ja, wieso wird das überhaupt betrieben und von wem eigentlich?
Und da sind halt meiner Meinung nach auch Scheinargumente unterwegs. Denn es heißt ja immer, es wird ja gerade zum Beispiel, wenn es auch um Kontrolle des Netzes geht und das Telefonnetz, sämtliche Kommunikationsformen, geht es ja immer, a, um Großkriminalität, also es wird ja auch nicht von Kleinkriminalität geredet, sondern es geht um die Großkriminellen, die, wo dann natürlich jeder rechtschaffende Bürger auch sagt, gut, die sollen ja auch gefasst werden, klar, das will ich ja auch nicht. Da muss man sich auch vor Augen führen, dass organisierte Kriminalität natürlich längst völlig andere Techniken benutzt. Also wo, ich glaube jede Polizeidienststelle hat Schwierigkeiten, da auch nur ein Zehntel mitzukommen, weil da einfach eine Menge Geld vorhanden ist. Das heißt, die schreiben sich garantiert keine E-Mails. Wir treffen uns morgen zwölf in der Alten Eiche, davon kann man ausgehen. Also das ist ein Scheinargument, weil da ganz andere Techniken im Einsatz sind und auch mit viel mehr Geld gedreht wird, als bei uns allen hier irgendwie mit unseren Kommunikationseinrichtungen. Und das nächste sind natürlich Schlagworte wie, weiß ich nicht, Pornografie im Internet und die Kinder schützen und so. Das ist dann auch immer ganz wichtig.
Da wird es dann auch emotional. Da kann man aber überhaupt schon gar nicht mehr rational argumentieren, wenn da erstmal so eine Mütterschar vor einem sitzt und aber unsere Kinder.
Also diese Feindbild-Generierung ist da irgendwie ziemlich klar zu beobachten. Also nachdem irgendwie der Ostblock weg ist, muss halt irgendwie der Kram finanziert werden. Und dazu wird halt organisierte Kriminalität benutzt. Und zwar schon seit etlichen Jahren, muss man schon sagen. Und diese Lautangriffsnummer, die wir da gerade gesehen haben, war sozusagen mehr oder minder das Finale eines ziemlich langen Prozesses, der halt auf mehreren Ebenen läuft. Auf der einen Seite wird halt heftig darüber berichtet, wie schlimm die organisierte Kriminalität ist. Auf der anderen Seite werden die Drogengesetze so gestaltet, dass die organisierte Kriminalität natürlich ein hervorragendes Auskommen hat, solange irgendwie die Drogen ordentlich verboten sind. Und auf der anderen Seite wird tatsächlich ein sich gegenseitig aufschaukelndes Stimmungspotenzial geschaffen, was halt tatsächlich dazu führt, dass die Leute klarlaufen, dass das prima ist, wir müssen doch was gegen die organisierten Kriminellen tun.
Oder um es mal anders zu formulieren, also an das mit dem Finale, was der Frank eben sagte, glaube ich nämlich irgendwie nicht, dass du irgendwie... Vorläufig, vorläufig. Ich hab mich noch nicht mal mit dem Sicherheitsbeauftragten der Telekom darüber da halten, da gibt es seit Januar kam mal so eine Meldung im Spiegel Online, irgendwie, dass die Telekom jetzt auch abfragen auf ihre eigene betriebsinterne Teradatenbank, sozusagen den Sicherheitsbehörden gegen horrendige Bühren, zwar aber eben zur Verfügung gestellt. Das heißt also die Möglichkeit, diverse suchen in den Daten zu machen. Das heißt, man kann jetzt auch abfragen, wer eine Telefonnummer gewählt hat. Also von wo ein Telefonanschluss angerufen wurde. Und das eben auch im Zweifelsfall Monate im Nachhinein. Dadurch, dass es da eine Datenbank gibt, wo alle Verbindungen an der Telekom gespeichert sind. Und das ist eben so eine Sache, wo man auch irgendwie so ein bisschen so den Eindruck hat. Und ich hab die Telekom halt aus einer Veranstaltung mir da ja auch schon gescholten. Hab gesagt, also eigentlich diese Datenbank wurde für was ganz anderes mal eingerichtet. Und jetzt auf einmal wird sie eben so komisch auch für so ein Überwachungsverfahren eingesetzt. Und da sagte hinterher zu mir, naja, er kann das schon irgendwie verstehen, dass ich da so meine Kritik hab. Für ihn sei das insofern ein bisschen erstaunlich, dass das irgendwie auf vielen Veranstaltungen, die diese Systeme und über diese Sachen reden, auch diese ganzen Befugnisse, die sie in staatlichen Stellen einräumen müssen. Und es sei schon längst nicht mehr so wie, sagen wir mal in den 80er Jahren, wo also viele Leute ja Empfindlichkeiten hatten, irgendwie Angst vor dem Überwachungsstaat oder was auch immer, sondern vielmehr würde die Telekom beispielsweise eben sehr viel dafür gelobt werden, dass sie eben auch den Regierungsstellen helfen würden, also die organisierte Kriminalität und diese gesellschaftlichen Missstände zu bekämpfen. Und das stellt ja ganz konkret die Frage nach der Akzeptanz sozusagen des Überwachungsstaates oder der Überwachungsmaßnahmen auch und damit auch der gesellschaftlichen Ausgangslage. Wir sagen, wie sicher oder unsicher fühlen wir uns denn überhaupt, dass wir irgendwie, wie es in England auch zu beobachten ist, da sind ja schon sehr lange in beispielsweise in den fahrenden Bussen dort auch Kameras installiert, sodass der Busfahrer vorne also sehen kann, was sich oben im Bus abspielt. Und es ist nicht einfach so, dass irgendjemand sich da beobachtet fühlt, sondern im Gegenteil, die Leute finden das alle ganz toll. Die fühlen sich, sagen, dass sie sich also viel sicherer fühlen würden, also insbesondere Frauen eben, so zumindest. Also die Englader, die scheinen da tatsächlich so von der Mentalität so ein bisschen von überzeugt zu sein. Und ich weiß nicht, ob wir in so eine Stimmung hier in Deutschland auch anfangen und dass wir jetzt mal eher meine Frage, die ich den Hörern mal stellen würden, leben wir denn tatsächlich in so einem Gefühl von Unsicherheit, dass wir jetzt irgendwie diese staatlichen Maßnahmen alle wollen und sagen, ja Stasi.exe, naja, ist schon in Ordnung oder haben wir damit eigentlich noch ein Problem? Also ich fühle mich da schon teilweise in problematischen Zuständen. Auch weil, naja, also der Spiegel hat das klar und deutlich zitiert neulich aus einer Pressemitteilung des Bundesinnenministeriums, wo es um die Rede des Bundesinnenministers Manfred Kanzler an der Sicht der Lesung des Gesetzes zur Änderung des Grundgesetzes sowie des Gesetzes zur Verbesserung der organisierten Kriminalität im Deutschen Bundestag ging. Na gut, die haben sich vertippt. Aber das war für mich schon so eine freudische Nummer. Also naja, weil auch Bundestagsabgeordnete sind vom Lauschangriff ja ausgenommen. Wer schützt da eigentlich wen?
Andy hat eine Frage gestellt an euch. Ihr könnt anrufen, 031 für Potsdam, 70 97 110. Vielleicht wollt ihr ja einfach überwacht werden und überall Kameras haben und findet das gar nicht schlimm. Ruft uns an und sagt uns, was ihr denkt. Gleich gibt es einen Fritz Kurzinfo und danach werden wir mit euch telefonieren.
Ich bin ein bisschen schrecklich, dass die Leute da sind.
Tschüss. Nochmal wegen einiger Anfragen, Musik kommt vom Analog Club DJ Team. Das ist Abhörmusik. Und wir können euch die einzelnen Titel natürlich nicht sagen. Das ist ein Tape von denen zusammengestellt.
Wenn Fritz im Raumanger mündet, dann 100, 1.
Null Uhr 32.
Wende.
US-Präsident Clinton muss sich nicht wegen angeblicher Sex oder Bedächtigung der früheren Staatsbediensteten Paula Jones in einem Zivilprozess verantworten. Die zuständige Richterin ordnete gestern die Einstellung des Verfahrens an. Die Klägerin habe ihre Vorwürfe so unzureichend untermauert, dass ein Prozess gegenstandslos sei. Ritual. Die Bemühungen um ein Bündnis für mehr Lehrstellen sind zunächst gescheitert. Bei einem Treffen von Bildungsminister Rutgers mit Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften gab es keine Ergebnisse. Nach Angaben der Gewerkschaften werden im Herbst mindestens 70.000 zusätzliche Lehrstellen gebraucht. Störfall. Wegen eines Lexem-Kühlsystems ein Reaktor des Atomkraftwerks Ignalina Litdown abgeschaltet worden. Es sei aber keine Radioaktivität ausgetreten, erklärten die Betreiber. Zwischenfall. Unmittelbar vor Beginn des Halbfinalsspiels der Champions League zwischen Real Madrid und Borussia Dortmund kam es am Abend im Stadion von Madrid zu einem Eklat. Fans des Gastgebenden Teams rissen Verbindungsstangen ein und brachten so eines der Tore zum Einsturz. Dadurch begann das Spiel erst 75 Minuten später. Es endete kurz vor Mitternacht mit 2 zu 0 für Madrid. Im zweiten Halbfinale besiegte Juventus Turin den AS Monaco mit 4 zu 1. In dieser Nacht zeitweise Regen, Abkühlung auf 6 bis 10 Grad. Morgen im Fritzradio lande weiterhin Regen, dann 8 bis 15 Grad. Zwei Meldungen von den Autobahnen A2 Hannover Richtung Berlin zwischen Wollin und Brandenburg bis 2 Uhr Verkehrsbehinderungen wegen Brückenbauarbeiten und A10 Dreieckspray auch Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Liederlehm und Königswüstehausen bis 1 Uhr Behinderungen wegen Bauarbeiten.
Matthias Kalkow mit dem Fritz, kurz ein Faux.
Live in Berlin.
Sonntag, 6. September.
Der Freilich für die Wuhlheide.
Präsentiert von Frips.
Weitere Kurzmeldungen.
Chaos Radio, Kurzmeldungen, zweiter Teil. Spaß mit Winzel war ich die erste. In Office 98 hat sich Microsoft mal wieder was tolles einfallen lassen. Zweistellige Jahreszahlen, kleiner 30, werden einfach als ein Jahr jenseits der 2000er-Marke interpretiert, um bei der Übernahme von fehlerhaften Datenbeständen nicht auf die Nase zu fallen. Wie die Übernahme von korrekten Datenbeständen realisiert werden soll, ist dabei noch unklar. Spaß mit Winzel war ich die zweite. Auch das beliebte Programm Microsoft Excel nimmt es mit dem Datum nicht so genau. Die aktuellen PC-Versionen der Software gehen beim Jahr 1900 klar von einem Schaltjahr aus, was es nicht ist. Dies führt zu zahlreichen Problemen bei der Berechnung von Tagesabständen und Ähnlichem. Ob der Fehler bewusst eingebaut wurde, um im Jahr 2000, auch bei dem zu erwartenden Zeitsprung ins letzte Jahrhundert, den 29. Februar trotzdem noch begehen zu können, wurde nicht bekannt. US-Regierung, US-Vizepräsident El Goa musste Jungs Peinlichkeit auf sich nehmen, da ein Bürocomputer durch simple Fehlbedienung einem 71-jährigen Ex-Senator keinen Geburtstagsgruß sandte, sondern ein Dokument, das dem Jubiljahr zu Geburt seiner Zwillinge gratulierte. Nichtsdestotrotz hatte der Ex-Senator eine Menge Spaß und bedankte sich artig für den tollen Geburtstagsspaß. Telefonspaß Mit einem simplen Trick aus dem Repertoire des Social Engineering verschafften sich unbekannte, kostenlose Telefongespräche um die internen Funktionen der beteiligten Telefonanlage wissend, riefen die Teilnehmer an und gaukelten einen Serviceanruf vor. Freundlich gebeten, drückten die angerufenen gerne die Tasten 9-0-RAUTE und schalteten den Sozialingenieuren eine neue W-Leitung frei, die sich darüber sicherlich freuten.
Es ist kein Schimmer mehr, ob die beiden Leute, die ich schon vor den Nachrichten hier jetzt herangenommen hab, die noch da sind. Hallo? Nee, da nicht mehr. Nur den anderen noch. Auch nicht mehr. Aufgegeben. Aber es sind noch genug andere da, die anrufen. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Andi, hallo.
Du musst mal dein Radio leise machen, Andi.
Ja, hab ich schon.
Echt? Dann bist du an der Funke oder was?
Ja, kannst du mich einigermaßen hören?
Ja, es geht.
Okay. Pass auf, ich ruf deshalb an, weil ich mich ein bisschen zu diesem Sicherheitsgedanken anschaue. Ich arbeite in einem großen Kaufhauskonzern in der Sicherheitsabteilung und wir beobachten alles per hoch technisierter Computertechnik und Videotechnik mittlerweile. Weil einer von euch in England dieses Beispiel brachte, dazu wollte ich mal was sagen. Ich selbst bin noch sehr viel im Internet unterwegs und ich arbeite viel, ich mach auch Musik mit Samplern und so ne Sachen privat und habe eben diesen Job. Für mich ist die Beobachtung nach nunmehr 15 Jahren, wo in diesem Sicherheitsbereich die Technik immer weiter vorangeht, einfach die, dass du auch wirklich immer mehr siehst. Das heißt immer mehr aufdeckst, immer mehr beobachtest und immer mehr, jeder hat ja von dem Thema Kriminalität im Internet und Kriminalität im Alltag, auch immer mehr feststellst, dass immer mehr Kriminalität auch stattfindet, was natürlich auch ein sozialer Punkt ist, klar. Aber du deckst auch einfach immer mehr auf.
Findest du denn, wenn du sowas beobachtest im Kaufhaus, hast du denn die Ahnung, dass die Leute, also sagen wir mal die Anderen, dass sie das auch mehr akzeptieren? Also diese Kameras und weiß ich was?
Ein ganz interessanter Punkt ist ja, wenn du als normaler Verkäufer in so einem Kaufhaus arbeitest, stehst du ja im Grunde auch ständig unter dieser Beobachtung, ohne dass du wirklich beobachtet wirst, weil der Mitarbeiter in unserer Abteilung beobachtet nicht einen Verkäufer. Aber du könntest ja als Mitarbeiter in so einer Abteilung sagen, das geht nicht. Ich popel mal in der Nase oder ich spreche mal mit einem Kollegen und ich bin mich ständig beobachtet. Dieser Gedanke findet überhaupt nicht statt. Überhaupt nicht. Das finde ich hochinteressant irgendwo. Also es kommt niemals jemand zu uns und sagt, sag mal, beobachtest du mich auch?
Ist das die Leute, die stillschweigen, davon ausgehen?
Sie nehmen stillschweigen, kennen alle. Also stillschweigen oder nicht, das ist die Frage. Ich meine, in so einer Konzernen gibt es Betriebsräte und es gibt noch Möglichkeiten, sich dazu zu äußern. Und diese Äußerung findet einfach nicht statt.
Aber vielleicht auch aus Angst davor sozusagen, überhaupt durch Nachfrage aufzufallen?
Die Frage vorhin war ja, findet bei uns schleichend schon so ein Prozess statt, die ja in England im Grunde schon sehr auf dem Vormarsch ist. Jeder Platz, jeder größerer Platz, im Grunde Videos erwacht wird. Und das kann ich, und das ist eigentlich der Sinn meines Anrufs, nur mit Ja beantworten.
Andy, du hast gesagt, dass durch diese, du hast selber erzählt, im Kaufhaus wird eine ziemliche Technik eingesetzt und es wird natürlich dadurch auch, werden sicher mehr Klauereien aufgedeckt und Diebstähle und so weiter. Aber hast du denn den Eindruck, also jetzt als jemand, der sich mit der Technik auskennt und der jeden Tag damit zu tun hat, hast du denn den Eindruck, dass sich das lohnt? Und zweite Frage, hast du den Eindruck, dass das wirklich der Grund ist? Der Grund, warum diese ganze Technik installiert wird.
Ja, also man darf sich jetzt unter der Diktatur nicht mehr den ehemals pensionierten Polizeibeamten vorstellen, der jetzt quasi drauf ausmarschiert, sondern die Sache ist schon ein bisschen mehr Füssigkeit, sagen wir mal, vonnöten. Und es ist auch vonnöten, dass du dich mit den Inventuren auseinandersetzt. Es geht ja weit darüber hinaus. Taschendiebstähle, Vergewaltigung und Treppenhäuser, Ausbruch von TKWs und Radioausglauben.
Aber ja nicht alles das in Kaufhäusern.
Doch, doch, doch.
Im Parkhaus?
Also wirklich alles. Alles das, was ich jetzt erwähnt habe, wird abgedeckt. Nur mal so zur Information. Aber um die Frage zu beantworten, es lohnt sich.
Was meinst du damit?
Naja, aber ich meine, das ist auch so ein bisschen, wenn du sagst, es lohnt sich, es klingt für mich so ein bisschen ein Weisermann, hat man mal gesagt, in dem Moment, wo man einen Hammer in die Hand nimmt, dann sieht die ganze Welt wie Nägel aus. Das ist auch so ein bisschen, also auch so überhaupt dieses Prinzip der Überwachung. Das heißt ja auch, dass man den Leuten nicht traut. Es gibt ja auch...
Okay, also die Frage kann ich nicht beantworten.
Nein, das ist ja... Moment, Moment, das war jetzt keine Frage zunächst, aber das war erst mal nur eine Feststellung. Weil es ist ja so in dem Moment, wo man Leute verdächtigt, dass sie was Böses tun, begibt man sich einfach in eine bestimmte Beziehung zu ihnen. Und dann entsteht auch sozusagen das Gegenteil von Vertrauen und dann fangen die Leute auch an zu klauen.
Nee, nee, Moment, Moment. Ich sehe es jetzt mal objektbezogen. Genauso, weil wir eigentlich reden über das Internet. Ich sehe es jetzt mal objektbezogen. Objektbezogen bedeutet, Kaufer aus X, Y hat so und so viel, jetzt mal ganz pauschal gesagt und ganz negiert, hat so und so viel Inventurdifferenz. Die wurde verursacht durch Personal so und so viel, durch Kunden so und so viel. Jetzt setzen wir Technik ein und wir bekämpfen das. Und wir beobachten mit einem Jahr, da gibt es Menschen, die dafür die Gelder freigeben und da gibt es natürlich dieselben Menschen, die dafür verantwortlich sind, dass die Gelder sinnvoll ausgegeben wurden.
Also ihr kennt diese Szene ja auch so ein kleines bisschen aus der Literatur und was sich für mich immer wieder darstellt, ist, dass der größte Teil des Anstiegs an Inventurdifferenzen gerade im Einzelhandel dadurch zustande kommt, dass die Leute einfach so super extrem saubermäßig bezahlt werden. Also Verkäufer irgendwie im Einzelhandel, irgendwie einen schlechteren, sklaven Job gibt es noch eigentlich fast nicht mehr. Und wenn halt sozusagen erstens die Mitarbeiter immer sich vor Augen halten, wofür mache ich das eigentlich für 12 Marki Stunden, und zweitens sich noch nicht mal sicher sind, dass sie ihren verdammten Job behalten können, dann ist natürlich klar, dass es ihnen total egal ist, ob da jemand irgendwie was mitnimmt oder wie dieser Kaufholzkonzern dazu steht. Also wenn der Konzern vielleicht das Geld, was in die Videotechnik steckt, dafür investieren würde, sich die Loyalität seiner Mitarbeiter zu halten, denke ich, wäre aber besser bedient.
Okay, aber das war jetzt noch gar nicht der Punkt. Der Punkt war doch, ob es sich lohnt, oder?
Na, da bist du wahrscheinlich auch nicht der richtige Ansprechraum. Aber die Frage ist vor allen Dingen, ob es sich lohnt. Also du wolltest wahrscheinlich gerade noch fortführen, dass das ihr schon mehr aufdeckt. Das heißt, insofern lohnt sich die Technik schon. Die Frage für mich stellt sich nur, geht sein Diebstahl zum Beispiel zurück dadurch?
Ach, na das nicht, um Gottes Willen.
Also ist es keine Bekämpfung sozusagen?
Nein.
Das ist nämlich dieses Wort, woran ich mich ein bisschen reibe, das ist dieses Lohnt, weißt du? Lohnen, was heißt es lohnt sich? Das lohnt sich vielleicht jetzt auf einer einfachen Vierteljahresbalanz fürs Kaufhaus und das sind irgendwie Zahlen auf einem Blatt Papier. So und wir, denke ich, betrachten eben sehr viel mehr, lohnt sich eigentlich jetzt diese Aktivität im Kleinen, die ja tausendmal multipliziert über ganz Deutschland, Europa und diese Welt überall stattfindet, lohnt sich das eigentlich für uns, für alle in dieser Gesellschaft. Und da sind wir ganz klar der Mann und das lohnt sich nicht die Bohne, denn durch diese ganze Nachforscherei, Aufspürerei und dieses permanente Erzeugen von Misstrauen jedem gegenüber, also ich gehe irgendwie in so ein Kaufhaus, gehe ich schon überhaupt nicht mehr rein. Ich meide Kaufhäuser wie Blöde und zwar nicht, weil eine Kamera auf mich zeigt, sondern weil ich da einfach nur weiß, ich bin da einfach nur noch so ein Arsch, der irgendwie an den Bildschirmen vorbei läuft und eine Nummer und sonst einfach überhaupt nichts und zwar gar nichts. Ich meide da nur aus irgendwie im schlechtesten Sinne einen Kunde. Dieses Gefühl bekomme ich überall, bei Behörden und überall. Aber davon ganz abgesehen ist natürlich diese Überwachungsgeschichte. Da lebt eine fette Industrie davon. Aber da haben wir gar nichts davon.
Dieses Gefühl ist natürlich extrem wichtig, weil wie du richtig sagst, dieses Gefühl, was du im Kaufhaus und auf Ämtern und so bekommst, legst du natürlich auch in deine kleinen sozialen Kreise wieder rein. Jeder, der in einer etwas größeren Stadt, klein ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr anders, lebt, der weiß, dass du eigentlich niemanden auf der Straße prinzipiell traust, wie es logisch wäre, sondern dem wird prinzipiell misstraut. Dieses Gefühl wird unter anderem auch durch solche Einrichtungen erzeugt.
Richtig. Nur, warum ich anrief, um das nochmal zu sagen, war ja, wie weit geht es gesellschaftlich? Der Anspruch, der andere Ansporn anzurufen war, weil ich habe einen Freund in England und ich kenne die Geschichten und ich weiß noch Bescheid, wie weit das gar schon ist, weiter als bei uns in Deutschland vorangeschritten ist und wie weit die Menschen letztendlich, sagen wir mal, sich regelrecht umpolen lassen, dazu, dass sie sagen, das verbreitet Sicherheit, sagen wir mal so. Und dem ist natürlich nicht so. Da muss ich euch völlig recht geben, es wird immer mehr und mehr und mehr Kriminalität stattfinden. Auf der anderen Seite immer mehr und mehr Aufrüstung. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Und der Sinn ist ja auch, gibt es Internet frei, also sagen wir mal, das folgt hier in den Gesprächsthema, also dieses Fernsehen-Thema, gibt es Internet frei, das reguliert sich irgendwann von selbst. Dazu wollte ich ja eigentlich nur einen Satz sagen. Also im Grunde genommen geht es mir darum, dass ich euch da völlig zustimme. Absolut, es gibt keinen Erfolg für sicherheitsverbreitende Menschen im weitesten Sinne jetzt mal. Da wird es nie einen Erfolg geben, auf gar keinen Fall. Es ist auch, wenn du als Polizist, nehme ich mal an, keine Möglichkeit, dass du, wenn du einen Täter stellst, der, was auch immer er getan hat, einen Erfolgsgefühl hat. Die Zeiten sind vorbei, davon bin ich ziemlich überzeugt. Also ich für mich jedenfalls ist das so. Und ihr kennt es von anderen auch. Aber um jetzt mal den Sprung zu machen von so einer grundsätzlichen Überwachung und zum Internet hin, ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass sich die Dinge selber regulieren. Das glaube ich eben auch irgendwo nicht. Und das wiederum, ja das hängt hier sagen, das sind meiner Meinung nach einfach politische Gründe. Das ist genauso wie, jetzt mal ganz im Blick, weil ich für die Firma SAP händeringend qualifizierte Mitarbeiter suche und der Grundstein dafür, dass die nicht da sind, wurde ja schon vor 15 Jahren gelegt. Weil Leute sinnlos in Umschulungen geschickt werden und dann ein überschwemmter Markt da ist und falsch umgeschult werden und und und. Das sind politische Gründe.
Das ist ja Marktwirtschaft, das hat ja nichts mit Regeln sich von selbst gesellschaftlich zu tun.
Also ich danke dir für deinen einen Beitrag und das eine, was man daraus sicherlich ziehen kann und was man auch übertragen kann, ist die Nummer mit dem Feind, weil es gibt keinen Feind mehr, nirgendwo. Und das andere Problem ist, ich meine, dass sozusagen das mit dem Hammer und den Nägeln schon noch irgendwo in der wirklichen Welt auch existiert, das weiß jeder, der mal in der U-Bahn und nach dem Fahrschein kontrolliert worden ist, anhand der Gesichtsausdrucke derjenigen, die diesen Beruf ausüben, weil die sind halt so drauf und die werden ja auch genau so gezüchtet und genau das kommt dabei auch raus, nämlich der Anreiz überhaupt schwarz zu fallen besteht ja auch daraus.
Ich möchte hier abschließend nur sagen, dass ich das überzogen finde, einfach wirklich und ich nicht davon überzeugt bin, weil ich einfach in der Materie bin und viele Menschen kennengelernt habe, in den 15 Jahren, die in dem weitestgehend in dem Bereich arbeiten, die wirklich nicht so...
Ich halte das ja auch nicht für ein Verbrechen in dem Bereich zu arbeiten, aber ich halte sozusagen das Grundprinzip dieses Arbeitsbereiches, wenn man den so nennt, das schafft natürlich Arbeitsplätze, es schafft auch Arbeitsplätze arbeitslos in die U-Bahn zu stecken, in Uniformen und den Leuten ein Gefühl von mehr Sicherheit zu geben. Bloß es hat eben nichts damit zu tun, nach den gesellschaftlichen Ursachen und nach den gesellschaftlichen Zuständen zu forschen. Und zu fragen, warum geht es denn hier eigentlich so ab? Warum klauen wir dann alle in Kaufhäusern? Oder wir scheißen alle die BVG? Vielleicht liegt es ja auch an den hohen Tarifen.
Was ich da immer sehe, ist, dass gerade mit solchen Sachen, wie diese Sicherheitsmitarbeiter, die werden dann immer wieder angesetzt, wo es halt einfach nur darum geht, eklatante Managementfehler zu verdecken, gerade bei der BVG zum Beispiel. Die bräuchten halt einfach keine Kontrolle, dieses Einsetzen, wenn irgendwie U-Bahn-Fahren 60-Fernig kosten würde. Also Herrgott statt 390, dann würde sich dann niemand Gedanken drum machen. Es wäre einfach so, dass die Verluste viel zu gering werden.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich der Punkt.
Und sobald einfach mal 1000 Kontrollertage weniger arbeiten, ist es auch billiger.
Das ist natürlich dieser Kostenfaktor überhaupt eine große Frage, ob sich das lohnt. Also ob der Schaden wirklich je höher die Preise sind, desto höher ist natürlich der Schaden, aber das ist ja immer so genau wie bei...
In so einem Kaufhaus kostet eine Technologie und die Mitarbeiter, die da sitzen, haben einen Haufen Stangengeld, das man erstmal wegklauen muss.
Vielleicht sind die sowieso alle nicht.
Jetzt wird letztlich weggeklaut. Da kannst du jetzt... Ich kann das nicht abschließen, ich will Bemerkungen machen. Meine persönliche Feststellung ist, ein Prozent oder vielleicht fünf Prozent wächst da auf pro Tag von dem, was wirklich ist, das weiß auch jeder.
Das ist ein Opfer, der die Gelder freigibt.
Eine Frage hab ich noch an dich. Ist euch schon mal eine Kamera geklaut worden? Also eine von euch?
So, Andy, dann sagen wir mal, in welchem Kaufhaus du arbeitest.
Nee, das mach ich nicht. Eine kurze Frage noch. Wie viel verdient denn in so einem Kaufhaus so ein durchschnittlicher Ladendetektiv?
Wie sag ich dir auf den Punkt zu, war wahrscheinlich im Durchschnitt so um die 4.000 Mark Brutto.
Aha, ist sozusagen eigentlich auch nicht wirklich lukrativ.
Mit Sicherheit nicht.
Also das ist nämlich noch eines der Problempunkte, dass diese Sicherheitsleute dermaßen notorisch unterbezahlt sind, dass sie eigentlich nur dadurch motiviert werden können, dass sie eine Uniform ankriegen und halt Macht über ihre Mitbürger bekommen.
Also pass auf, das heckt immer auf denjenigen ab, der den Job aushiebt. Also wirklich unbedingt.
Also wenn ich mir so angucke, so irgendwie die Typen liegen da so manchmal in der U-Bahnsee mit ihrem großen Hund irgendwie.
Ja, klar.
Das ist ja der... Also da decke ich mir irgendwie, wenn die jetzt kurze Haare und Springerstiefel eine Bomberjacke an, irgendwie, dann würde ich sie nicht wirklich für Sicherheit halten.
Aber das ist doch bitte, bitte nicht zwangsläufig bei jedem Fall.
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Was den Leuten durchs Hirn geht und durchs Herz geht und so, das sollte man vielleicht nicht immer gleich so pauschalisieren. Da würde mir viel dran liegen, wirklich.
Also, unbesehen, ich kenne auch einige Leute in der Branche, die relativ nett sind. Es ist halt nur so, dass für mich sozusagen es nicht irgendwie Sicherheit verbreitet, wenn da Leute stehen, die einfach unmotiviert und unterbezahlt sind.
Grundsätzlich nicht, hast du völlig recht. Genauso ist es. Das ist ein Grundgedanke in dieser gesamten Branche, der noch nicht aufgegriffen ist. Du darfst noch nicht verherzen, das sind keine Lehrberufe. Dahinter stehen keine großen Organisationen, die da ein bisschen die Hand drauf haben. Das beginnt jetzt erst langsam. Der Gedanke, dass man die Leute ausbilden muss, dass man den Leuten mehr als Recht und Gesetz beibringen muss. Nämlich auch ein bisschen was Humanes. Der ethische Gedanke, das fängt jetzt erst an.
Die Eskalation zum Beispiel.
Da kümmert sich natürlich überhaupt keiner drum.
Aber das funktioniert bei der Polizei auch nicht von daher. Das stimmt.
Das muss jeder selbst mitbringen. Und warum ich eigentlich dann, wenn ihr auf die Schiene schieben wolltet, unbedingt, was ich nicht so schön finde, sag ich mal ganz ehrlich, abschließend, dann denkt man auch mal ein bisschen darüber nach, dass es oft wirklich jeder Menschen, Individuum ist und jeder seinen Job, vielleicht doch manche nur in den Job drin gerutscht sind.
Das ist schon klar. Ich denke, du kannst davon ausgehen, dass wir das schon trennen. Also es geht nicht darum, jetzt irgendwie den Einzelnen da irgendwie gleich in eine Rolle zu schieben, sondern was Frank meinte, ist halt sozusagen die Wirkung, die davon ausgeht. Weil diese Leute stehen ja überall rum und sollen Sicherheit simulieren. Und bei mir erregen die einfach nur Frust. Ich habe einfach irgendwie das Gefühl, irgendwie Scheiße, wie da U-Bahnen fahren, mit den Affen, die da überall rumstehen, ihre Hunde an mir vorbeiziehen und irgendwie eine Fresse ziehen, als wären sie John Wayne, aber wenn da mal wirklich was passiert, dann dinsen die kurz mit den Augen und verschwinden in den nächsten Wagen.
Viele haben auch Frust, kein Thema, weiß ich auch. Viele haben den Frust, viele schieben den Frust, viele arbeiten für acht Mark die Stunde, die Frust wird in Brandenburg angesetzt, da kannst du noch niedrige Tarife nehmen und und und.
Dafür müssen sie dann im Zweifel sogar noch ihre Fresse hinhalten. Das ist nämlich dann, das macht halt keiner. Das ist nicht gerne. Andy! Wir haben nicht verstanden.
Okay, vielen Dank dafür.
Andy, erstmal, ja, danke für den Einblick und das war ein spannendes Gespräch und ich glaube, die ganzen Stereotypen, die dann so hin und her geschmissen werden, ich glaube, da hast du wahrscheinlich die Schnauze voll von, aber...
Ja, ein bisschen, aber ich verstehe es auch.
Ja, aber ich finde...
Das Bild, das ihr habt, stimmt ihm einfach auch. Nur wenn man dahinter guckt, sieht es ein bisschen anders aus. Könnt ihr auch nicht wissen, genauso wie ich wahrscheinlich hinter eure Sachen nicht gucken kann.
Aber dafür haben wir ja dich gerade ein bisschen gehört, um das ein bisschen zu korrigieren. Spannend, oder? Jetzt haben wir natürlich ein bisschen viel Zeit mit Andi verquatscht, aber dafür war es auch eines der bisher interessantesten Gespräche, finde ich. Wer ist denn da noch? Hallo. Janek, viel Zeit hast du nicht, aber wenn du noch eine Frage hast, kannst du dir noch loswerden.
Na, ich habe eigentlich keine Frage. Ich wollte bloß nochmals den gleichen Thema äußern wie Andi auch. Und zwar habe ich einfach das Gefühl, dass hier Sicherheitsdenken den Leuten oft obktriiert wird. Also beispielsweise meine Großeltern hier halt nicht in Waldweise Angst haben, dass dort jemand sitzen könnte, sie über uns wie über Fett. Und dann natürlich auch denken, dass jemand mit Uniform sie beschützen könnte.
Also das ist doch so ein Trend, den wir ziemlich eindeutig beobachten, dass halt gerade in Radiofernsehen und halt in den beliebten Berliner Boulevardblättern halt irgendwie genau dieses Gefühl halt auch massiv geführt wird. Also angefangen von irgendwelchen Fernsehsälen, wo halt irgendwie böse Kriminelle nur dadurch irgendwie erledigt werden können, dass sie halt illegal abgehört und irgendwie prinzipiell erschossen werden. Bis hin so zu der alltäglichen Berichterstattung über Kriminalfälle, die eigentlich irgendwie mit der Realität nicht viel zu tun hat.
Jetzt sind wir natürlich genau in der spannenden Ecke. Jetzt sind wir aber den sozial-gesellschaftlichen Problem.
Jetzt sind wir sozusagen da, wo wir eigentlich die ganze Zeit hinwollten.
Aber man braucht unglaublich viel Vorbereitung, um über solche Sachen ein bisschen reden zu können.
Wir brauchen einfach fünf Stunden. Wir müssen einfach den Night Flight auch noch zwei Moderatoren machen.
Ich habe überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn man so etwas weiter fortführt und vielleicht genau da ansetzt, weil mich so Geschichten wie Andy, der zum Beispiel von in Anführungsstrichen der anderen Seite mal ein bisschen erzählen kann und so, sind natürlich schon sehr spannend. Und wenn man das auf etwas eigentlich nicht mehr viel mit Computer zu tun haben, der ihre Ebene bringt, dann können sich sicher auch noch viel mehr Leute beteiligen. Aber jetzt ist erstmal Schluss. Jetzt gibt es einen Night Flight ab 1 Uhr mit...
Gebt mir noch Gelegenheit noch auf etwas hinzuweisen.
The One and Only Martin Petersdorf. Und vorher kann Tim noch auf etwas hinweisen.
Genau, nämlich auf unsere öffentliche Veranstaltung, also unser Treff, wir haben hier Klubräume in Berlin, in der Marienstraße 11 und wir machen da alle zwei Wochen am Donnerstag für technologisch, kreativ technologisch interessierte Leute einen kleinen Treffpunkt, das nennen wir Klub Descordia. Da kann man sich halt kennenlernen. Es geht da nicht darum, uns unbedingt jetzt kennenzulernen, dass wir uns da hinstellen und irgendwie Fragen beantworten, sondern wir haben da halt einfach unsere Klubräume und wer halt interessiert ist, irgendwie so in unserem Rahmen kreativ zu werden, technologischen, da würden wir doch vielleicht dahin kommen. Wir haben das am nächsten Donnerstag, also nicht morgen, sondern am 9. April und dann noch am 22. und im Mai geht es dann hoffentlich wöchentlich weiter. Schauen wir mal.
Und das Ganze ist nachmittags, oder?
Ach ja, richtig. 17 Uhr bis 23 Uhr. Aber das gibt es dann alles unter www.ccc.de, wo auch ansonsten alles interessante oder...
Na klar, die Papierversion, die kriegt ihr mittlerweile auch bei Lehmanns und heißt Datenschleuder ist ein kleines Heft und stehen nette sinnvolle Gedanken drin.
Ja, damit ist unser Pulver dann glaube ich verbraucht. Aber die Musik noch nicht.
Doch, die Musik schon lange.
Die Musik schon lange.
Kann doch gar nicht sein. Doch, dann drei Stunden.
Da kam mal irgendwelcher Rock gerade drauf.
Das war was anderes.
Da sind deine Lieblingsplatten hinten drauf.
Das war Chaos Radio Computer Blumen bei Fritz, aber eins hier in AdVide mit Martin Petersdorf, Chaos Computer Club und Johnny Sang.